. Musik Hey Leute, hallo Hannover! Was, wo, Hannover? Wow, ich habe mir zufälligen Ort gesagt, das ist gross, sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass ich genau Hannover getroffen habe. Freut mich, schön, dass ihr da seid. Das ist zu viel, ich glaube, Podcast sollte eine Grenze haben, eine gewisse Obergrenzepublikum. Holy shit, seid ihr viele Leute. Wahnsinnig viele Leute. Man sieht immer so wenig. Ich glaube, wir haben heute auch die grösste Bühne aller Zeiten. Wir hatten noch nie eine so grosse Bühne. Komm, wir schreiten mal ab. Ich fühle mich, als wäre ich in einem anderen Raum von Stefan. Es ist was ganz anderes. Hast du die neue Staffel Better Call Saul geschaut?
Nein. Hat irgendwer die neue Staffel Better Call Saul geschaut? Ey, einfach mal mit dem Spoiler anfangen, warum nicht? Ja, ich scheiße das einfach mal drauf. Hier in Hannover, weißt du, das Regelbuch landet im Mülleimer. So. Und zwar gibt es da diese neue Storyline. Das redende Buch wird Better Call Saul, also Harry Potter mässig. Also, und zwar gibt es da diese Storyline, ich hole viel zu viel aus dafür, dass es ein mittelmässer Gag wird. Das ist das Podcast-Sufo. Welcome. Es gibt diese Storyline von dem Typen, der dann, was später bei Breaking Bad das Labor unten wird, anfängt das zu bauen. Und die holen erst einen Franzosen und der kommt mit Laser und Jean-Appel und so und so weiter weißt du der ist technisch begabt und dann versagt er aber ist viel zu arrogant und holt den Deutschen und der Deutsche hat keinen Laserpointer, der Deutsche schreit ab. Sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn, elf, zwölf Meter ist die Bühne lang. Wow, jetzt verstehe ich, worauf es hinausgeht. Ich fühle mich ein bisschen bei so einem TED-Talk, der immer so, vor allem ich liebe ja den Anfang von TED-Talks. Mehr rhetorische Fragen, komm. Nee, nee, genau. Kennt ihr TED-Talks? Vor allem jeder, der den TED-Talk anschaut, hat sowohl entweder im Raum oder als YouTube-Video schon den Titel gelesen. Aber trotzdem tut jeder Ted Talk Speaker so, als müsste er jetzt noch auf den Titel hinleisten. Ja, fünf Minuten lang wirklich. Wenn Sie eine Farbe werden. Welche Farbe werden Sie? Ich weiß, dass es um Dinosaurier geht. Ich weiß, dass es... Schauen Sie jetzt mal nach links und nach rechts. Okay. Einer von diesen drei Personen. Hier ist ein Bild von meiner Tochter. Ich schaue es zu Hause und bei YouTube. Vor zwei Wochen erkrankte sie an Leukämie. Alles klar, ich will wirklich gern zum Dinopat. Mal Hand hoch, wer von euch hat Gelb gesagt? Ich lieb Triceratops, Brontosaurus, gib mir irgendeinen Scheiss jetzt! Wer von euch hat Gelb gesagt? Ungefähr 20%. Das ist genau die Prozentzahl von Leuten, die innerhalb der nächsten acht Jahre in einem Autounfall sterben werden. Das ist ein Bild von einem Auto. Okay. Aber warum will der Mensch unbedingt in den Weltall erobern? Weil er da ist? Schauen Sie mal nach links. Die eine Person und Sie, einer von euch beiden, wird mit einer Prozentschance von 0,4% eines Tages zum Mond fliegen. Okay, es wird spannend. Ich muss sagen, es catcht mich auf eine Art schon. Dinosaurier sind schon geil, oder? Ja, da sind wir. Muss man auch mal sagen, oder? Hier sind wir noch von jeder Sauer. Nein, Gott schon. Dinosaurier die ganze Zeit. Und man liked's, man liked sofort. Ja, und jeder Zuschauer denkt sich, ich weiß schon, worum es befriedigung dass er endlich beim thema angelangt ist ja ich liebe auch diese Geste das ist einfach die beste Geste aller Zeiten und die haben nichts mehr in der Hand weil da oft jemand sitzt der weiter drückt ja und manchmal ist es so ein bisschen asynchron toll toll Hannover ich hab als war ich ganz kurz ja das würde mich jetzt mental die ganze Ich habe einen Hannover, ich hab... sorry, ganz kurz. Ich wollte ganz kurz, weil das würde mich jetzt mental die ganze Zeit stören, ich habe einen Hannover-Gag. Jesus, den hat der schon drei in meiner Probe erzählt. Ich gehe einfach kurz von der Bühne, ich kann nicht noch mal an. Ja, die ersten... Pass auf. Übrigens, die Soundcheck-Leute hatten was zu tun, während er das gesagt hat, und sie haben trotzdem aufgemerkt und keine Reaktion gezeigt. Naja, man weiss ja nicht, was Hannover so für ein Ort ist, was ist das denn für Vibes, worauf habt ihr so Bock?
Sag mal ganz kurz Hand Hand hoch, wie alt seid ihr? Gut, bringt mir gar nichts. Deswegen, ich weiß nicht so, was der Comedy-Vib ist, deswegen habe ich beim Soundcheck den Gag geübt. Ich sag mal so, das erste Mal von den drei Malen ist er noch ganz gut angekommen. Ich guck mal, wie es läuft. Nein, Bufe. Okay, pass auf. Wir wollen ja so ein anderer Podcast. Die machen eine Tour nach der anderen, die gabeln das ab, die gehen da zum Buffet, zum Zuhörer-Buffet. Versteht ihr, was ich meine? Nein, niemand kann dem erfolgen. Die holen sich einen Zuhörer nach dem anderen, für die ist das Massenware. Wir lieben jede einzelne Stadt, die wir besuchen, und wir lieben auch Hannover, und deswegen habe ich einzig und allein für euch folgenden Gag präsentiert. Ich möchte nochmal auftreten dafür.
Das ist fucking Christ.
Kannst du mich anmoderieren, bitte? Hat jemand einen Tipp, frage ich mich.
Kannst du mich anmoderieren? Ja, okay.
Und hier kommt jetzt für euch mit dem besten Gag, den Hannover jemals gesehen hat, Florentin Will.
Dankeschön, Hannover, seid ihr da, habt ihr Bock! Ja, dankeschön, dankeschön. Hannover, ja. Folgendes, ich war letztens unterwegs auf der Strasse und da habe ich zwei Leute gehört, wie sie sich unterhalten.
Und ich denke mir so, was ist da los, was redet ihr, was kommt aus eurem Mund raus?
Sagt der eine zum anderen, ich war letztens in Hannover.
Und habe einen furchtbaren Komöden gesehen.
Pass auf, stopp, stopp, Leute!
Der eine sagt der eine, ich war letztens in Hannoverover und dann sagt der andere, was machst du in Hannover?
Wow, das war, wow, ja okay, es funktioniert. Ja, ja, buh, das ist mit, aber der Comedian, der auf die Bühne kommt und erst mal, der erst mal so lacht, der Typ, ich nenne mal, der, der, ich hab kein Material Comedian, dieser typische, der erstmal... Der Stefan Tietze sozusagen. Sorry, sorry, ist ein Downer. Jeder kriegt ein kostenloses T-Shirt. Nein, nein. Das ist so leicht. Das kannst du nicht jedes Mal machen. Wir müssen kurz was nachtragen, was in Mannheim passiert ist, was mich nicht loslässt. Es kam zum Vorfall. Und zwar haben wir nach der Bühne erfahren, es spielte sich die ganze Zeit schon ab, während wir noch auf der Bühne standen, oben unsere Witzchen gemacht haben, kam es zu diesem Vorfall. Und zwar sind zwei Leute reingekommen, die keine Tickets. Ja. Und man hat einfach ausverkauft, da kamen einfach irgendwelche Leute rein, die hatten keine Tickets für uns. Noch schlimmer, die hatten nicht nur keine Tickets, die hatten sogar Tickets für was anderes. Für die Veranstaltung, die kein Scheiss nebenan stattgefunden hat. Die hatten Tickets für Faisal Kawusi Stand-Up nebenan. Und die haben sich gedacht, ich stelle mich da an, wo Leute stehen, und haben sich dann leider bei uns angestellt. Und dann haben wir nachher erfahren, die sind die ganze Zeit da geblieben. Und das finde ich nach wie vor mega lustig, dass die einfach in Minute, in Sekunde zehn gemerkt haben, das ist eine ganz andere Show. Das ist was, dafür habe ich nicht bezahlt und sind geblieben. Das ist mega cool. Haben wir vielleicht heute auch Leute von, wer wurde zu Joe Cocker heute Abend? Wer hat Bock, schön, ah, das ist ja schön eine Person, sehr gut. Joe Copper, hat er Joe Copper gesagt? Ich kenne mich aus mit Musikgeschichte, ich kenne mich ein bisschen aus. Aber ich meine, wenn es möglich ist, mit Faisal-Kawusi-Tickets hier reinzukommen, wer ist dann noch hier heute drin? Was braucht man, um hier reinzukommen? Man kann mit jedem Ticket der Welt offensichtlich hier reinkommen. Es ist nicht so schwer. Da guckt schon jemand ganz beschämend auf die Füße, haben hier ein Katy Perry-Ticket so. Aber das finde ich wirklich sehr lustig. Es war, das war wirklich, es hat, it made my day. Haben wir leider erst nachher erfahren. Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite, ab welchem Punkt würde man dann auch rausgehen? Das ist auch noch die Frage. Warst du schon mal im falschen Kino, falscher Film? Nee, nee, noch nie. Doch, ich war auch schon mal in einem falschen Kinofilm, aber man merkt es ja auch erst die ganze Zeit nicht, weil man hat so das Plakat gesehen von so einem blutrünstigen Monster. Ja, man denkt erst noch, es ist der Trailer. Also es ist ein langer Trailer. Es Ist ein sehr langer Trailer. Und der Trailer verrät schon den ganzen Anfang des Films. Ich glaube, so sind auch Filme entstanden. Man dachte sich, oh Leute, Trailer sind so geil, mach die mal länger! Ja, mach die mal länger! Mach die mal 90 Minuten lang! Mach mal 90 Minuten Trailer! Der längste Trailer aller Zeiten. Ich finde, das ist eine gute Idee. Waren Filme eigentlich immer genauso lang wie jetzt oder gab es auch mal so eine Phase, wo die achtunden lang einfach lang waren und leute gesagt haben das ist einfach zu krass macht da vier teile draus oder so gute frage ich weiß nicht glaube ich glaube das fing an mit peter jackson der wollte einen film machen und hat gesagt macht drei raus ja so ich kenne mich auch aus mit filmgeschichte ähnlich wie bei twix wo man gesagt hat mit dem schokoriegel macht zwei draus macht doppelt so viel das ist eigentlich wenn ihr was machen wollt, macht doppelt so viel. Wenn jemand sagt, ich will Geld verdienen, warum nicht doppelt so viel? Warum nicht noch mehr? Und dann, was auch noch lustig war, ist, nach Mannheim sind Dinge passiert, Leute. Dann kam es nämlich dazu, es war ja die Presse da, muss man sagen. Oh ja. Und wir haben uns ja auch schon so ein bisschen über Regionalzeitungen lustig gemacht an dem Abend. Und tatsächlich kam danach im Mannheimer Morgen ein Artikel über uns, über unseren Auftritt, es war jemand da. Wir wissen nicht ganz genau, welche Show die Person gesehen hat, denn anscheinend hat sie einen Florian Will gesehen. Genau, richtig, sie hat Florian Will gesehen. Genau, falls ihr jemanden seht, der so ähnlich aussieht wie ich,
meldet euch auf jeden Fall. Es könnte Florian Will sein, er ist in eurer Nachbarschaft. Wir haben ihn noch nicht fassen können, wer weiß.
Und ich sage nur so viel für heute Abend zur Vorbereitung, seid nicht so streng mit uns, auf
den letzten paar Metern gehen uns die Gags aus. Das hat der Mannheimer morgen postuliert, was im Mannheimer
morgen steht. Lediglich auf den letzten Metern ging den zwei ein bisschen die Puste aus, aber war immer noch gut, freilich oder so war erstand da. Ja, eigentlich wollte ich Faisera-Kawusi sehen, aber war auch nicht schlecht. Weil er anscheinend ist ja meine eigene Schuld, wo ich bin. Hannover, weisst du irgendwas über Hannover tatsächlich, hier hier wurde Kabale und Liebe Uhr aufgeführt von Schiller. Ja, Schiller Facts, Schiller Facts, ich habe eine App auf meinem Handy, es sind diese Schiller Fun Facts Apps. Und je nachdem, wie der Stadt du bist, sagt die dir, dass da Kabale und Liebe Uhr aufgeführt wurde. Jeden Tag zwei Nachrichten von der Friedrich-Schiller-Gedächtnis-App und es nervt. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich sie deinstalliere. Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, aber falls ihr euch fragt, wo Kabale und Liebe aufgeführt wurde, hier, und falls ihr euch fragt, was zur Hölle sind Kabale, ich hab keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung, was ist Kabale? Auch damals bei der Abnahme meinten sie auch, Kabale und Liebe fand ich ja ganz geil, aber kannst du nicht, was Kabale? Die fand ich besonders gut, die Kabale, die erste Kabale oder die zweite Aber Kabale und Liebe war nicht der Film, wo dann Kabale und Liebe und Zombies rauskamen, ne? Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung. Was war das denn immer für ein Film? Kabale und Liebe und das Biest? Stolz und Vorurteil und Zombies. Stolz und Vorurteil und Kabale und Liebe und das Biest. Ich würde gerne Kabale und Liebe und Zombies sehen, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist ein guter Film. Kabale gegen Zombies. Kabale klingt für mich auch wie so ein Tier. Kann ich. Oder ein Kabal! Ach, ich habe jetzt neuerdings diesen Kabal. Willst du mal meinen Kabal sehen? Na, das klingt für mich auch wie so ein Tier. Kann ich nicht. Oder ein Kabal!
Ach, ich habe jetzt neuerdings diesen Kabal. Willst du mal meinen Kabal sehen? Na, das klingt jetzt wieder anders. Weiß ich nicht.
Mein Fisch ist gestorben.
Also willst du nicht meinen Kabal sehen? Heißt das nein?
Wir wollen ja heute auch mal eine andere Seite von Stefan Tietze sehen, weil Stefan Tietze ist der erfolgreiche Instagram-Live-Influencer.
Influencer.
Aber heute auch mal eine emotionale Schiene abziehen. Wie geht's dir eigentlich mit dem...
Ungefähr vor einem Jahr ist es passiert,
da ist ein Fisch gestorben.
Und Stefan Tietze,
ja, das ist genau das...
Jeff. Und wie du siehst,
in unserem Herzen lebt er weiter.
Dieser kleine Kampffisch.
Kampffisch. Läuft so eigentlich eine Therapie
ab, so? Mir geht's heute schlecht.
Ich glaube, das ist exakt das, wie Therapie im Ideal verläuft. Ein Publikum, was klatscht ab und zu. Man sagt, du bist ein guter Typ, eigentlich im Kern. Aber du bist jemand, du sprichst nicht so oft über deine Gefühle. Ich rede nicht so oft über meine Fische. Ich muss sagen, ich habe ihn nicht vergessen, auch weil ich wollte nicht das Aquarium danach wegschmeißen, ich habe es geleert und dann in die Ecke gestellt. Aber ich habe mich noch nicht dazu durchgerungen, es zu verkaufen, jetzt da verkaufen können. Aber unterbewusst bin ich noch mal irgendwann Kampffisch, obwohl ich genau weiß, niemand wird so sein wie Jeff. Ich glaube, das Traurigste, was es gibt, ist ein leeres Aquarium. Man weiß einfach, hier ist irgendwas schiefgelaufen. Ja, irgendwas ist schiefgelaufen. Also ein Ende hat auf den letzten Metern gemerkt, fuck, ich habe eine Fischallergie. Das funktioniert nicht nicht oder es ist irgendwas Schreckliches passiert. Rückblickend auch Quatsch, dass ich den von so einem Züchter in Taiwan hatte oder sowas. Und ich denke mir so, viele geben sich weniger Mühe, einen Hund zu besorgen, so ein intelligentes Geschöpf, als ich mit meinem scheiß Fisch. Aber ist der dann eigentlich auch geflogen aus Taiwan?ogen aus Taiwan? Geflogen? Ja, der Fisch, wie kam der hierher? Er schwang. Ach so, du schlimmst aber schon nach Deutschland, ne? Jetzt nicht abhauen! Nee, du musst schon so ein Adresse draufklicken. Nee, jetzt guck mich nicht so an! Was, wo sind deine Mundwinkel, guck mich nicht so an! Ich glaub, der ist geflogen tatsächlich, ähm, ich hab einen Kumpel, der, äh, pfuh, das ist ja, ich darf nicht so laut auswarten, man tut mir leid. Ich habe einen Kumpel, der mit Pferden fliegt manchmal, dessen Job es ist. Wir reden wieder über Timo, der Kumpel, der mit Pferden fliegt. Der Markus. Und der Markus reitet beruflich Pferde ein. Und der verpflichtet man nicht mehr mit denen und kann einfach kostenlos aber ich glaube schon erzählt kann kostenlos nach L.A. fliegen manchmal wenn er seine Pferde dann fertig eingeritten hat, also ausgeritten und dann die rüberbringt in die fahrreinigsten Staaten von Amerika. Und hat dann das Flugzeug auch so ein Anhänger dran, so ein Pferdeanhänger, wenn die Pferde auch so rausgucken, ist das Grödland? Die gucken nicht raus. Doch, die gucken raus. Mich nervt man sich noch die Hintern von Pferden. Das nervt mich. Warum ist da schon die Wand vorbei? Warum muss man nicht auf diese Ärsche von Pferden gucken, wenn man im Stau steht? Entschuldigung, die können die einfach ein bisschen höher machen, diese Wand. Dann haben alle das Problem, dich. Mach den Fernseher hinten drauf, dann kann ich wenigstens was gucken oder so. Ich glaube, Stefan Ties ist der einzige Mensch, der möchte, dass Tiere noch mehr eingesperrt werden. Ja! Was soll denn das Fenster sein? Ihr macht da zu! Was soll das denn sein? Mehr Wand, ich bin für mehr Wand. Lass sie da rausgucken. Ja, und das Irre an der Geschichte ist, Florentin, dass der in den Frachtraum darf. Nein! Ja, ich sag's doch. Wie gross ist so ein Frachtraum? Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich müsste dringend mal wieder mit ihm reden. Aber da ist wirklich, da ist dann ein grosses, grosser Frachtraum und da kann er dann reingehen. Und was ich Wahnsinn finde, ich dachte immer, der wäre gar nicht zugänglich von der Kabine aus. Ist er offensichtlich, das müsste ja rausgehen, über den Flügel, über den Flügel. Man kann vom Flugzeug aus in den Frachtraum. Ja, offensichtlich, klar. Irgendwo ist eine Tür und dann gehst du einfach rein und da ist ein whole new world. Einfach, ich stehe mal vor, dass so ein Pokertisch ist, wo so Leute einfach so illegale Pokerrunden fahren schneiden. So drei Pferde sitzen da und einen Kampffisch. Und ein Kabale. Da sind diese dreckigen Kabalen. Ja genau, und dann kannst du einfach in diesen Frachtraum gehen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da genau ist. Ist das nicht wahnsinnig galt in so einem Flugzeug? Ich glaube doch, ja, ich glaube doch. Vor allem, was passiert? Druckabfall. So, dann kommen in der Kabine kommen die Masken runter. Kommt für das Pferd auch noch Masken runter? Grosse Pferdemaske? Das stimmt. Die scheissen auf die Pferde, das ist völlig egal. Immer wenn man hört, Flugzeug abgestürzt, und man denkt, oh, die Menschen, da waren drei Wale drin. Einfach, die hingen unten dran. Einfach. Außer der, der, der, gut, die Babywale haben wahrscheinlich nicht überlebt, weil man ja erst sich selber helfen soll und dann den Babywalen. Das stimmt. Ich würde das nicht, jedes Mal, wenn ich im Flugzeug sitze und diese Anweisung sehe, ich denke mir, ich würde das nicht machen. Ich würde niemandem helfen. Nee, sollst du ja auch nicht. Nee, ich würde auch nachdem ich fertig bin, niemandem. Also man muss ja auch, es gibt ja so zwei Seiten von einem selbst, die Seite, die man den anderen präsentiert und die Seite, die so im Frachtraum von einem drinsteckt und Poker spielt und die Person sagt, ne, ich helfe da keinem. Dem helfe ich nicht, dem helfe ich nicht, dem helfe ich auch nicht. Es gab dieses wahnsinnige Foto, wo jemand, da gab es ja diesen Druckabfall und die Leute haben natürlich Selfies gemacht, klar, wann fallen schon mal diese Maske runter. Und auf diesem Selfie hatten alle die Maske falsch auf. Alle hatten die nur über den Mund und nicht über den Mund und Nase. Und die eine ist, dass dir niemand zuhört und sagt, wer überlebt jetzt? Oh, ist ganz schön schwierig, oder?
Nur ich und dieses Pferd. Alle ersticken.
Oh, wohin, wo es in die Ausgänge geht?
Macht's gut, ihr Trottel, zack.
Aus dem Notausgang raus.
Ich fahr jetzt ihr ganzes Leben lang.
Ich frag mich, wann Ryanair, weil Ryanair will ja für alles aufpreist.
Wenn du was zu essen willst, wenn du Beinfreiheit willst.
Wenn sie raus wollen.
Wann sagen die, wenn ihr so eine Gasmaske wollt, dann schön noch zwei Euro drauf. Das ist mir zu sozial kritisch, Stefan. Nee, das ist mir zu sozial kritisch. Ich hab keinen Bock auf diesen spitzen sozial kritischen Namen. Die nehmen sogar Kabel raus aus dem scheiß Flugzeug, damit du mehr Beinfreiheit hast. Was für ein Kabel haben die da rausgenommen? Brauchen wir die Flügel wirklich? Lass uns mal einmal probieren einfach. einfach um das versuchen, auch scheiss mal einfach. Ja, und jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, wissen wir wirklich, warum Flugzeige fliegen? Oder ist es nur so ein Ding, das einfach läuft seit Jahren? Das hat funktioniert, stellt sich in Frage. Ja, und es funktioniert einfach. Lass uns mal das Cockpit weglassen. Lass uns mal gucken, ob noch was geht. Lass uns mal diese Flügel hinten. Diese Flügel hinten, die machen nix, die machen nix, das ist wie die letzte Reihe, ja, ich seh euch, ich seh euch, es ist wie die letzte Reihe, diese Flügel hinten, die braucht keinen Menschen, die braucht, nee, sorry, ist ja so, wirklich. Ich finde euch toll, ich finde euch mega gut, folgt mir Ed Stephan Tietz ein. Nein, nein.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie was machen. Dieser eine Flügel, der nach oben steht. Ja genau, diese Haifisch-Krosse. Der immer so dabei ist, der auf jede Party eingeladen wird. Sehr spezielle Comedy. Diese Haifisch-Krosse hinten am Flugzeug, oder? Im Ernst, wovor braucht man die? Am I right? Der ist immer dabei, der ist auf jede Party eingeladen, aber man fragt sich, was macht der eigentlich? Wie bei so einer Gruppenarbeit in der Schule, wo man sich die ganze Zeit fragt, was hat Raphaael gemacht hat raffael für seine vier minus wirklich gearbeitet und dann kam die präsentation und er hat die folien weitergeklickt und du denkst auch du bist ein part der gruppe zack zack das ist die beste geste mehr gut ich würde gern so was im alltag haben wo man einfach dinge komplett ändern kann so eine ganze wand einfach zack das ist ein bild von der erde Zack, ist meine tochter zack ich habe eine tochter die reihenfolge ist schon wichtig dass du die ja ja ja ja apropos er kinder ich habe jetzt ich habe neffen ich habe nichts geleistet ich habe überhaupt nichts geleistet aber herzlichen glückwunsch wusste ich auch nicht meine gesamte meine gesam gesamte Leistung an der Sache ist, dass ich einen Bruder habe, was technisch gesehen nicht meine Leistung ist. Nicht ganz meine Leistung. Und man denkt sich ja so, ich finde so Neffen sind wie so der First Draft, so ich schreibe mal alles hin, so der Probelauf. Wo man sich denkt, den Neffen kann ich verhauen, um mein eigenes Kind zu proben so ein bisschen. Deswegen überlege ich mir jetzt immer beim Neffen, was würde ich machen, wo würde ich eingreifen, wo muss ich eingreifen, ja wo sehe ich die Behandelnden falsch, da muss ich rein. Und ich weiß nicht, vielleicht mal die Runde öffnen, wir haben 600 Mikrofone unter den Stühlen kommt einfach und die werfeigste podcast aufnahme wer hat mit da so laut kurzer einschub apple wirbt jetzt damit dass bei facetime man bis mit bis zu zweiunddreißig leuten telefonieren kann das ist die hölle das ist buchstäblich die hölle zweiunddreißig leute aber alle alle haben Lefens und hören sich nicht und haben Delay. Ja, das ist so die Kino-Präsentation.
Chat up to thirty-two people.
Nalalalalala! Der ganze Saal schreit einfach. Und letztens habe ich ein Bild von einem Neffen gesehen, kleines Kind, kleines Ding.
Ich habe ein Bild von einem Neffen gesehen?
Nee, nee, nee.
Von deinem Neffen. Ach komm.
Ist der denn süss geworden?
Ja.
Der First Draft? Weiß. Was heißt, ja, ich glaube es gibt zwei Arten von Menschen. Die, die alle Babys süss finden und die, die alle finden, dass Babys aussehen wie ein Frosch. Und man denkt einfach so. Also asiatische Babys sind süss, so eine Zehn von süss, sorry, die sind einfach, die haben riesengroße Augen.
Bisschen konterintuitiv.
Du meinst Pokémon, glaube ich.
Ich mein Pokémon.
So Manga-Augen.
Und ganz kleines, die liegen immer auf dem Rücken, die sind so, wie sie, die können nix.
Ja, ja.
So, das ist, mag, nee, fällt mir nicht.
Ist das wirklich am sichersten?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Und jetzt könnt ihr immer sagen, ob ihr da eingreifen würdet als Onkel. Also wo greift man als Onkel ein? Ich will ja der coole Onkel sein. Ich werde Onkel sein, der ihm dann so GTA 4 gibt. Pass mal auf. So 2090 gebe ich ihm so, hier, pass mal auf, hier, ist ein gutes Spiel. Gutes Spiel, so, pass mal auf. Und hier kennen Sie schon Twitter? Nice. Hier ist ein Playboy. Die ersten drei Seiten kannst du nicht mal lesen, aber der Rest ist noch ganz gut. Ha, Onkel, was ist das? Der Onkel bin ich. Warum klebt es? Ich bin der Onkel, der immer Geschenke geschenkt zu Feiertagen, die nicht existieren. Einfach so, hier kriegst du deinen ersten Playboy zum Playboy-Tag. Zu künsten. Ist Uefner tot? Ja? Ja. Selbstverständlich. Ja, ist das so. Eure Antwort schneiden wir raus. Ich schneide direkt mein selbstbewusstes Ja rein. Klar. Oh Mann! Das habe ich auch nicht mitbekommen. Wie oh Mann! Leute sterben halt, das ist der Lauf der Dinge. The Circle of Life. Elton John. Lebt Elton John noch? Ja, ja, ja ja und also zu meinem neffen würde die eingreifen ja oder nein und ja definitiv einfach oh süss er ist meine pflicht als onkel es ist meine pflicht als onkel und das problem an kindern ist ja dass sie nicht selber entscheiden wie sie leben also man sieht man schaut sich stefan tietze an und man sieht eine Menge falsche Entscheidungen. Viele Entscheidungen, aber viele Entscheidungen getroffen. Ja, aber es sind seine eigenen Entscheidungen. Richtig. Und bei Kindern, die haben keine eigenen Entscheidungen, weil die Eltern alles entscheiden für sie. Und deswegen ist es die Frage, wo muss man ihn schützen vor dem willkürlichen Willen ihrer Eltern. Und dieses Kind hat ein T-Shirt an und auf dem stand was drauf. Und da stand drauf, I love London.
Das Kind ist ein Jahr. Eingreifend, eingreifend.
Und da dachte ich mir, wirklich?
Wow, dann sag mir doch mal was über London.
Du liebst London, das ist das, was du mit einem Jahr machst.
Oh, der Big Ben, ey, der Big Ben, da muss man mal.
Ey, oh, Pille, Dick, Pille, Picc heißt es, Piccadilly, Dick, Piccadilly, Dick, Piccadilly, Dick, Piccadilly, Dick, Piccadilly, Dick, Piccadilly, ey, da gehe ich, oh, geil, alter, wirklich, richtig gut, richtig gut.
Und dann dachte ich mir, du liebst London nicht, du liebst London nicht und die Frage ist, muss ich da eingreifen und vor allem, warum zieht man seinem Kind I Love London T-Shirts an? Warum gerade London? Warum das? Das ist ein Trend, und dann gibt es natürlich auch den Trend Fussballverein. I Love Borussia Dortmund, wo man sich auch fragt, ja, tust du das? Aber gute Frage, warum macht man das? Ich glaube, man produziert seine eigene Liebe, man will schon sein Kind beeinflussen im Alter von zwei Tagen. Aber geht das denn, Also das wäre ein psychologisches Instrument. Haben wir Psychologiestudenten hier drin? Psychologiestudenten? Nein, gut. Falls ihr... Ah doch, hier haben wir. Sehr gut, wunderbar. Dann macht ihr doch mal den Test. Ja, okay, oder? Und ein psychologischer Test wäre zum Beispiel, man hat eine grosse Gruppe Menschen, 40 Menschen, 20 Menschen zieht man Metallica-T-Shirts an, den anderen neutrale T-Shirts. Und dann guckt man, wie sich der musikalische Geschmack entwickelt. Vielleicht mögen die am Ende dann auch irgendwie Blue oder so. Wie lange geht das Experiment? 20 Minuten. Wir sind alle Studenten, wir haben keine Zeit, wir haben keine Zeit, wir müssen Online-Poker spielen.
Out of touch, ich habe keine Ahnung, was Studenten so machen.
Nach 20 Minuten...
Was machen Studenten? Online?
Online-Poker.
Online! Da hat jemand noch mal gelacht, da hat jemand noch mal Online-Poker gesagt.
Da hat sich jemand so sehr über den Gag gefreut, dass er ihn wiederholt hat. Nicht so schlecht.
Hör dir die Folge noch mal an, du kannst dich selber hören, wie du sagst, online! Warum sollten wir Ihnen den Job geben? Pass mal auf, hier drücken Sie mal Play. Hier, Minute 35 62. Brück einfach mal Play. Online, okay, Sie haben den Job. Sie haben den Job. Mir ist warm, ey, Leute, mir ist echt warm. Jetzt bin ich warm schon dieses Gekrissel zu sehen. Und die ganze Klasse hat er irgendwas von schwarzen Löchern und coolen Relativitätsscheiß erzählt und so. Und wir haben aber dieses Gekrissel, dieses Wow, schwarze gegen weisse Punkte. Ja, Wahnsinn. War viel spannender. Wahnsinn. Das ist sein neuestes Mittel im Podcast, so von Merchers auf dem Weg, keine Sorge. Ja, Mer Weg, keine Sorge. Genau wie tatsächlich zum Thema Schule im Bio-Unterricht hatten wir ein Skelett und an dem konnten wir dann sehen hier. Hat auch ein Arm gefehlt? Es fehlt immer ein Arm. Es fehlt immer ein Arm. Oder ein Arm. Okay, wenn ein Arm nicht fehlt, ist der andere, auf jeden Fall ist ein Arm im Schritt. Das ist immer so, da wurde immer den Schrittgegen geschoben. Und wir durften ihn benennen. Und das war dann immer so, das ist der interaktive Teil des Unterrichts.
Ansonsten Hardcore-Frontalunterricht.
Benennen.
Benennen, ja.
Also im Sinne von ihm ein Namen geben.
Skeleton Mac Skeleton Face halt.
Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Ja.
Und unser Skelett hieß Paul.
Und das ist alles, was ich über Biologie weiß.
Also, na ja.
In allen von uns ist ein Paul und ich mach das fertig. Ja. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ich es hinkriege, jemals ein Kind zu bekommen, ehrlich gesagt, weil ich habe im Bio-Unterricht nicht gut aufgepasst. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Neffen kann ich, Kinder keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung. Großteil der... oder? Knochen? Sorry, ich bin immer noch bei Paul gerade. Hast du das Skelett verstanden? Nee, nicht hundertprozentig. Was ist zwischen Knochen? Knorpel. Okay, wir machen fortwarte. Und dann, aber wie, ich bin, man ist verloren. Also ich weiß nur, dass ein gruseliger Skelett man in mir wohnt und wenn man Röntgenbilder macht, dann kommt er zum Vorschein und das ist nie gut. Röntgenbilder sind nie gut und immer very unsettling.
Der ist wirklich drin, ne? Das ist wirklich gruselig. So ein Schädel-MRT, wenn du dein Gehirn siehst, das ist furchtbar. Wissen viele nicht, will ich die meisten nicht, ich glaube, es wissen zwei Leute in meinem Leben, aber ich habe einen gutartigen Tumor in meinem Kopf.abe ich das schon mal erzählt? Nein. Geil, Leute!
Ihr klatscht fürs richtige Team.
Leute, das ist der Hannover-Humor.
Aber es war nicht leicht.
Hoffentlich ist nicht der Hannover schon morgen da.
Aber ihr klatscht fürs richtige Team.
Ihr klatscht für den gutartigen Tumor.
Und damit habt ihr schon mehr richtig gemacht. Habt ihr Bock auf gutartigen Tumoren? Yes! Die besten Tumore meiner Meinung nach. Es ist der beste... Was sagt ihr zu bösartigen Tumoren? Geht aus! Scheißtumor! Ja, aber das ist der Macht wirklich nichts. Weil man muss immer irgendwann, man wollte herausfinden, warum ich so gross bin.
Oh Gott, das klingt wie der schlechteste Film aller Zeiten. Ich muss herausfinden, warum ich so gross bin.
Und dann verlibe ich mich in die schöne Ärztin.
Guter Trailer, schlechter, langer Film. Zu lang. Und viel zu kurzer Trailer.
Und dann tatsächlich haben die erstmal eine Hand geräumt. Das macht man halt. Um anzureden. Dann erstmal, wir können auch Hände röntieren. Tatsächlich sind da dann die Wachstums- keine Ahnung, Spurrillen. Also es ist jedenfalls Platz, die ist mit in die Wiege gelegt, wie groß du wirst, weil dein Körper hat gewisse Wachstums-Zwischenräume zwischen den Knochen. Und dann werden wir wieder Knochen. Die musst du halt ausfüllen im Laufe deines Altersprozesses, während der Pubertät und so, werden dann diese kleinen Wachstums-Zwischenräume immer kleiner, bis irgendwann Knochen auf Knochen stösst und dann ist es auch schon gut, dann ist es so gut wie vorbei. Und bei mir haben die herausgefunden, dass ich so ungefähr 1,85, 1,90 werde. 85 1 90 werde haben sich ein bisschen vertan moment mal in welchem alter hast du diesen test gemacht aber nicht vierzehn fünfzehn ich dachte jetzt so wie du jetzt bist nein einfach so warum bin ich so groß das ist eine impression von mir zu mir warum bin ich so groß warum bin ich für gross star wars star wars Star Wars, Star Wars! Ja, ihr kennt... Gross, gross, gross! Mit dem ATS hier kannst du dich identifizieren, das ist so dein Spurled Animal, gross, lange Ball. Und dann tatsächlich haben die dann gesagt, ja gut, er muss einen anderen Grund haben, dass er noch grösser wird, als diese Wachstum zwischen noch mehr erlauben. Und dann haben sie meinen Kopf geröntgt, weil sie Angst hatten, dass da ein Tumor ist.
Und tatsächlich haben sie einen gefunden, aber einen ganz, ganz, ganz kleinen und tatsächlich macht man, die meisten machen halt diese MRTs nicht und die meisten haben die dann gesagt, wahrscheinlich um mich zu beruhigen, um mich zu verarschen, aber die haben gesagt, dass sehr viele diese Tumore haben, aber es halt nicht wissen, weil die wenigsten halt in ihrem Leben so einen Gehirnscan machen. Und ich habe wirklich einen, der auf die Wachstumsdrüse drücken könnte, aber ein bisschen zu klein ist.
Das heisst, ich bin zu gross, die Röntgen, um herauszufinden, warum ich zu gross bin, finden an der Stelle auch was, aber sagen, ja, das macht nichts. Das heißt, wir entlassen unser Publikum heute mit dem Wissen, dass die meisten von euch einen Tumor im Kopf haben. Ja, geht noch zum Merch, dann hol ich wir ein T-Shirt. Wow. Aber wie, aber wenn du sagst kleiner Tumor, was ist ein kleiner Tumor? Ich habe keine Veränderung. So ein bisschen Nadelöhr. Öhr, buchstabieren wir bitte mal das Wort Öhr. Öhr. Ich hätte es ähnlich buchstabiert. Tatsächlich dachte ich mal irgendwann, ich wäre bei Hangman total schlau, man hat nur zwei Striche hingemacht, man wollte das Wort Öl, weil ich dachte mir, niemand kommt auf Öl, niemand rät Ö, L vielleicht, aber dann ist halt Strich L, was soll das sein? Und dann habe ich herausgefunden, dass es gegen die Regeln ist, gegen die einzige Regel, dass umlautliche Polizei, hat dich verhaftet. Ach, wo du sagst, Biologie sind so, wir haben auch heute bei der
Hinfahrt hast du ein Foto von mir gemacht, wie ich geschlafen habe im Zug, so, und gut, früher hat man halt Penisse aufschlafen, Leute,
gemalt, das macht man halt augenscheinlich Fotos, toll, ganz großartige Leistung und ich habe eine wahnsinnige Applaus, also ich bin, bin ich echt zugenommen und diese Uhr, die trage ich immer nur bei Podcast-Uvo-Aufzeichnungen und in Mannheim hat die mir noch gepasst und jetzt gewillt das so rechts und links daneben raus. Ich habe ihn halt von wie viel war das jetzt drei Wochen massiv zugenommen. Was hast du gemacht? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe gebacken, tatsächlich. Du hast dich selbst gebacken. Ich habe ihn aufgehen lassen. Ich habe so einen Kuchen gebacken, auch so ein Netflix-Doku. Das fand ich cool. Da gab's bei Chef's Table eine tolle Pastry, ein Pastry-Chef, Christina Toasty. Oh ja, sehr gut. Ein Applaus für Christina Toasty. Aber nur von denen, die sie kennen. Danke an alle, die geklatscht haben, obwohl sie die Person nicht kennen. Wenig Anerkennung, dafür sehr ehrlich.
So ist Hitler groß geworden.
Ist so.
Und am Ende haben alle geklatscht.
Applaus für die Klappe! Sehr gut. Ihr könnt einfach applaudieren, wenn ihr wollt. Ja, und sie hat irgendwann den Crack Pie gebacken, was einfach nur wahnsinnig viel Zucker ist und Ei.
Und die ist halt so eine wahnsinnig erfolgreiche Michelin-Stern ausgezeichnete Nachtisch-Chefin.
Buchstabier Michelin? M-I-C-H-Ö-L-Ö- Im Prinzip wie Öhr. Richtig, sehr gut. Warum gibt es bei uns in Deutschland eigentlich keine fucking Buchstabierwettbewerbe?
Warum kennt man das Nordamerikanische Film?
Ich weiss, vielleicht sind Deutsche zu klug und können einfach schreiben, das ist kein Problem.
Kann sein.
Amerikaner, House.
Genau, Nazi.
H.
Zieht langsam die Waffe, aber okay, du hast gewonnen.
Die Waffe oder ein iPhone, google das.
Okay. Was? Ich hab, hey, Moment, Moment, Moment, du meinst jetzt so, iPhone ist die neue Waffe und irgendwie Populismus greift um sich. Ja, ich war ein bisschen, ich hab viel gewollt von diesem Weg. Wie viel von diesem Kuchen hast du gegessen, Stefan? Offensichtlich zu viel, okay, und dann habe ich, das ist wirklich nur quasi sehr viel Zucker, brauner Zucker, und weil das nicht reicht, noch sehr viel weißer Zucker und Eigelb und so weiter. Und dann ist die Umrandung des Kuchen ist dann einfach quasi Keksteig, den man dann vorher macht und dann zerbrüllt man den Cookie und dann ist das die Umrandung. Das ist wirklich eine Sünde, dieser Kuchen. Und den habe ich gemacht, einfach aus Scheiss. Das war so ein Tag, wo ich dachte, ich lebe wie Sims. Wie ein Sims. Weil das war ein Tag, ich habe ein Bild gemalt, einen Kuchen gebacken und einen Film geschaut. Ich habe ein Freund gewonnen und ein Liebchen. Und das ist Wahnsinn. Ich dachte mir, genau so müssen sich Sims fühlen. Und es war auch so, ich bin nach Hause gekommen und dann dachte ich mir, jetzt jetzt ein Bild malen. Und bin halt, hab schlagartig die Richtung gewechselt und bin so, ich hab mir jetzt eine Staffel aus Langeweile eine Staffelei gekauft. Und ich bin dann da hingelaufen, die stand plötzlich da, weil nicht mehr jemand, da kam diese lustige Musik und dann kam plötzlich mein Wohnzimmer umdekoriert und dann war dann eine Staffelei. Und dann hab ich ein Bild gemalt, einen Kuchen gebacken, ein Buch gelesen und dann war ich ein Pluspunkt schlauer. Ja, wirklich. Sehr schön. Aber das war ein cooler Kuchen. Und sie hat in der Dokumentation gesagt, dass sie sich nicht getraut hat, zunächst den Kuchen zum Verkauf zu geben, zum Verkauf anzubieten. Weil das so, es ist, normalerweise verkaufst du halt Nusskuchen oder meinetwegen Himbeertorte oder sowas, aber das war einfach nur so ein Zuckergemisch, was halt irgendwie geil ist aus so einem Grund, weil Zucker halt an sich, kannst du auch Zucker löffeln, das ist ganz geil. Und dann hat sich das halt einfach irgendwann mal, hat sich Chefs jetzt zu überreden, das einfach mal zum Verkauf anzubieten und ich hab das immer nicht verstanden, ich dachte mir, komm, du hast einen Michelin-Stern, so, dann willst du ja wohl wissen, wenn etwas so gut ist, dass es zum Verkauf anbieten kannst. Dann hab ich diesen Kuchen nachgemacht, habe den probiert und der war wirklich mehr gut.
Und dann habe ich...
Moment, der besteht aus Zucker und Ei, oder was?
Primär, ich habe ein bisschen überspitzt,
aber es ist natürlich auch noch Sahne drin,
es ist noch Milch,
es ist alles, was dick macht, Butter, sehr viel Butter und Milchpulver.
Da bin ich durch die ganze fucking stark gerannt,
um Milchpulver zu finden.
Milch und Milchpulver?
Ja, nee, keine Milch, nur Milchpulver. Und dann haben die mich mal zur Babynahrung geschenkt gebührterweise. Aber es gibt auch einen guten ausgewählten Backläden. Da ändert mein Vokabular, bei Milchpulver ändert mein Vokabular als eine Einmalstrasse. Und tatsächlich habe ich dann gedacht, warum traut ihr sich nicht, dieses Ding hinzustellen?
Dann habe ich diesen Kuchen fertig gemacht und dachte mir, den nächsten Tag bringe ich den mit in die Firma und gebe den den Kollegen. Und ich habe es verstanden. Man traut sich nicht, den hinzustellen und zu sagen, ich habe euch diesen Kuchen gebacken, weil diese Konsistenz ist wie so ein Maßriegel, so karamellig, total geil im Prinzip, aber niemand weiß, was es ist. und ich backe nie und dann bringe ich da diesen Kuchen mit, der aussieht wie so ein Kind, hat im Sandkasten gespielt und alles zusammengeworfen, am Ende draufgepinkelt und das Leutnant gestellt. Und so sieht das einfach aus, diese Torte, und dann kommt plötzlich Stefan, der jeden Tag kommt und immer in seinem Büro verschwindet und am Ende des Tages rausgeht, bringt plötzlich eine Torte, so einen Kuchen mit und stellt ihn da hin und man weiss nicht, was es ist. Und ich habe es verstanden, aber es war am Ende ganz cool und die Leute haben es gemocht. Wow, das heißt, du hast die ganze Firma fett gemacht jetzt. Ja, das ist richtig, ja. Holy shit. Uiuiuiui. Oh mein Gott. Was eigentlich auch eine gute Möglichkeit ist, anstatt abzunehmen, alle in seinem Umfeld fett zu machen einfach. Ah, clever. Einfach,. Ich glaube, deswegen viele Leute backen auch so gerne. Ich würde in meinem Leben nie backen. Du hast gesagt, ich habe aus Scheiss gebacken. Na, iss. Du hast gesagt, du hast aus Scheiss gebacken. Und ich denke mir, warum sonst? Also da sagt er, muss jemand backen, hat jemand die Notsituation zu backen? Klar. Deswegen glaube ich, das ist auch, wir gehen auf Weihnachten zu. Ja. Und da, glaube ich, hat man wieder die Chance, schön weniger zuzunehmen als alle anderen um sich herum, um damit besser abzuschneiden. Ich glaube, das ist eine gute Strategie. Wahnsinn, auch Marzipan, das ist ja einfach nur so ein Block, einfach nur so Scheiss drauf, hier ist einfach nur Kalorien. Ich muss lange nicht, was das ist. Wie lange dauert es noch, bis einfach reine Kalorien verkauft werden? Einfach so 400 Gramm Kalorien einfach. Aber eigentlich ganz praktisch. Das darf ja nicht jeden Tag, ja. Aber ich mag es einfach. Eigentlich ganz praktisch. Weil dann kannst du halt gut zählen, wie viele Kalorien. Weil jeder Mensch braucht eine gewisse Anzahl am Tag, brauchst du ja eine gewisse Anzahl an Kalorien. Das ist natürlich gut, da kannst du sehr gut aufpassen. Wie dieses Zeug, was wir immer ausprobiert haben, wo wir beide keinen Bock mehr drauf, Juhl, viel Spaß bei eurem Twitter-Feed mit der Werbung dafür.
Richtig, es reicht, dass wir es hier einmal gesagt haben,
und ihr habt den Rest eures Lebens Juhl-Werbung in eurer Zeit.
Ist das nicht seltsam?
Ist das nicht seltsam, dass alle Leute, alle von euch, WC-ente Werbung bekommen haben?
Ja, ist schon komisch, ne?
Ist das nicht weird?
Warum?
Vor allem, also Theorie eins, Szenario eins, die hören unseren Podcast und haben sich gedacht, wow, diese Chance müssen wir nutzen. So, Theorie zwei, alle von euch haben danach, das ist die wahrscheinliche Theorie, haben danach mal WC-Ente bei Google eingegeben und wart bei eurem Google-Konto eingemeldet. Und die haben gesagt, okay, da interessiert sich jemand für WC-Ente, ballern wir den damit zu. Oder Version Nummer drei, wir machen eine Kooperation mit WC-Ente und ihr greift mal unter euren Stuhl. Ja, jeder kriegt eine WC-Ente heute Abend mit der Räume. Richtig, jeder hat was. Die Leute zu Hause sehen das nicht, dass ihr nichts habt. Die trauen sich auch gar nicht mehr unter ihr, da ist richtig viel Geld unter dem Stuhl, aber sie trauen sich jetzt nicht mehr. Aber ist schon lustig.
Man sieht immer dumm aus, wenn man irgendwas vom Boden aufhebt. Das hat wirklich die Menschheit nach oben, die Menschheit immer nach oben, oben, oben, Sonne, Mond, Merkur, ja, die wollen da hin.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, den Boden...
Wer will nach unten?
Ja, genau, niemand will nach unten.
Aber eine Rakete steigt auch nie nach unten. Warum fliegt man nicht, was ist unter uns? Warum fliegt man immer weg von, also warum fliegt man immer zum Mond oder zur Sonne? Ich glaube, das stimmt, man war auf dem Mond. Ist der Abstand zwischen Mond und Erde weiter als die Erde tief ist? Ja. Ja. Ja. Ich habe gesagt, ja, ja. Hier ist ein Bild von Mond. Das ist nicht sein Ernst. Vielen Dank, dass Sie bei meinem dass wir einen tag waren macht's gut ich applaudiert für dummheit moment das heißt man könnte anstatt auf den mond zu fliegen boring und auch einfach durch die erde durch nee nee ist jetzt erstmal darum dass man mal in den Südpol. Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch Doch, fliegt doch hoch, fliegt doch hoch, fliegt doch! Nee, ich meine nur mal, dass man sich den Südpol von unten mal anguckt. Irgendwie, weil man diese ISS-Bilder, da postet Alexander Gerst Köln oder das Himalaya, Dieb zwei hauptsächlich, aber nie mal den Südpol genau von unten. Manchmal von unten drauf geguckt auf die Erde. Warum fliegt man niemand da unten? Es gibt ja auch diese Flat-Earth-Theorien, wo im Internet viele Leute diskutieren, ob die Erde flach ist. Diese Handys neuerdings, boah, blenden die wahnsinnig. Und letztens wollte ja jemand von den Flat-Earth-Leuten, der behauptet, die Erde sei flach, wollte beweisen, dass sie flach ist, indem er mit einer selbstgebauten Rakete in die Luft fliegt und von oben ein Foto macht, dass die Erde gar nicht flach ist, abgestürzt gestorben.
Wirklich jetzt? Schade. Das heißt, Leute...
Das erübrigt sich von selbst das Problem. Ja, genau. Das ist ganz interessant.
Aber ich würde die auch gerne mal einfach an so Raketen setzen. So einfach mal an so eine Rakete setzen und mal irgendwie mit der ISS um die Erde schießen.
Vielleicht ist das deren Plan. Vielleicht wollen die in den Weltraum und sagen einfach,
wir nerven so lange die Leute mit der flachen Erde, bis die NASA sagt, okay, jetzt mal alle,
die es glauben, in den Bus hier und dann sagen sie. Aber die sagen nur, aber in Wahrheit geht's
genau, die brauchen wir nämlich, um Kontakt mit den Maulwurfmenschen aufzunehmen.
Endlich, diese fucking Kabale, die müssen eh nämlich um Kontakt mit den Maulwurfmenschen aufzunehmen. Endlich! Hier, das ist unser Menschenopfer. Die müssen eh weg. Zack. Ja, clever. So werden wir die alle los. Ist doch gut. Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, ich bin Maulwurfmensch, ich habe unglaublich schlechte Augen. Unsere Hände, diese kleine, du hast immer sehr kleine Finger, die haben sehr viele kleine Finger, aber so sehr viel Schaufeln. Das stimmt. Warum gibt es Bilder von Maulwürfen? Warum wissen wir, wie Maulwürfe aussehen? Dann sind die am falschen Ort gewesen. Es ist ja eigentlich sind dann zum Beispiel letztens so ein Buzzfeed-Artikel gesehen, die zehn effektivsten Tarnungen von Tieren. Wo ich mir dachte, jedes Tier, das auf dieser Liste steht. Nope. Nope. Ihr habt verloren.
Ja, das ist völlig richtig.
Ihr habt einfach direkt verloren.
Chameleons, wir wissen, dass es euch gibt.
Wir haben euch nur noch nicht gefunden.
Ihr seid aber auf Platz eins.
Ne, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich würde gerne mal einen Chameleon haben zuhause.
Vielleicht hast du schon eins.
Vielleicht habe ich schon eins.
Wer weiß. Vielleicht ist mein ganzes Wohnzimmer voller Chameleons. Im Badezimmer wieder die ganze Chameleons hier, hau ab! Aber wenn man jetzt so ein Chameleon, wenn das so langsam durch mein Wohnzimmer geht, bist du gerade cool, cool. Erzähl. Wenn so ein Chameleon langsam durchs Wohnzimmer geht und dann vorm Fernseher stehen bleibt,
ist es dann wie, als wäre man Fernseher... wie viele Pixel hat ein Chäleon langsam durchs Wohnzimmer geht und dann vorm Fernseher stehen bleibt, ist es dann wie als wenn man ein Fernseher...
Wie viele Pixel hat ein Chamäleon?
Ich glaube, du siehst dann einfach die letzte Sendung nochmal, da die zu langsam ist.
So ist ja auch die Zeitlupe entstanden.
Und Aufnahmerecorder.
Im Mittelalter konnte man sich alles nochmal durchs Chamäleon angucken.
Ja genau.
Was, wer hat jetzt genau wen erstochen?
Zack.
Also Torlinientechnologie.
Wir schauen kurz aufs Chamäleon. Toll. Der Schwarze Ritter hat schon wiedergeboren. Wie jedes Jahr. Schwerzer Ritter. Scheiss, schwarzer Ritter. Riesenproblem waren die. Ich fände es sogar, dass in der Vergangenheit immer ein konkretes Problem hatten. Neandertaler hatten Säbelzahntiger und im Mittelalter der Schwarze Ritter. So alle hatten immer so ein konkretes Problem. Neandertaler hatten Säbelzahntiger und im Mittelalter der Schwarze Ritter.
So alle hatten immer so ein konkretes Problem.
Dinosaurier,
Tyrannosaurus Rex. Ja, Kometen.
Was ist unser Problem? Vor allem, es gibt ja das
Neandertal als Tal, das ist ja ein Ort,
die heissen ja so, weil die da gefunden wurden.
Richtig, das ist ein Neandertal.
Das habe ich dir heute erzählt, du scheiß Arschloch.
Es gibt ja diesen Ort, wo kann der sein? In der Nähe von Köln, glaube ich. Wirklich? Das heißt, es gibt aber... Wo, Herford? Herford. Herr was? Ich habe keine Ahnung verstanden, alle rufen da. Das sind Tim und Till, die sprechen immer gleichzeitig. Der eine hat eine Freundin, der andere nicht. Merkwürdig. Ich versuch's nochmal. Herkrat. Herkrat. Sehr schön. Das heißt, es gibt aber Leute, die leben im Neandertal. Es gibt die Neandertaler Nachrichten. Ja, es gibt auch Radio Neandertal, oder nicht? Eigentlich schon. Guter Sender. Hey, wir sind's wieder, Radio in Andertal. Ja, wir wissen's, Uga, Uga, Uga. Hier ist Fucking Ronan Keating mit Live is the Rollercoaster. So kommen wir zu den Nachrichten, am Bahnhof wurde jemand mit einer Keule erschlagen. Och komm Leute, ist das euer Ernst? Sind das die echten Nachrichten oder schiebt die uns immer nur unter? Okay. Neandertaler. Neandertaler? Meinst du, der Mensch entwickelt sich noch gross weiter? Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. So dass wir so noch so ganz lange Zähne im Mund haben? Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch. Wie auf diesen T-Shirts, wo man am Ende, diese cleveren Shirts, wo alle am Ende auf ihr Handy schauen. Oh, ey, du hast schon drei von fünf sozialk kritischen Anmerkungen erledigt heute, mehr dürften es nicht sein. Wow, wow, kreativität! Wieder applaudieren Sie für Dummheit, Leute lieben Dummheit, da ist ein Mikrofonständer. Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, das ist nicht einfach ein Telefonständer. Telefonständer?
Das ist nicht einfach ein Telefonständer?
Telefonständer? Das ist nicht einfach was anderes.
Ich glaube, es wird bald zu einer Trennung kommen. Zwei von drei im Podcast-Ufo-Team werden vielleicht ohne das dritte Mitglied weitermachen, oder? Er hat, du hast noch nichts beigetragen.
Weißt du, wir reissen uns den Arsch ab und überlegen hier, improvisieren hier rum und so was, und von dir kommt gar nichts. Es hat so ein bisschen was von so einem Nazgul, von so einem Ringgeist. Aber so mit dem Gewicht von Lena Maylandrut. Wenn Lena Maylandrut die Nazgul wäre, das wäre ja das ihre Figur. So eine spitze Kapuze. Es ist aber auch so ein bisschen der Chill-Out-Nazgul, so ein bisschen der Nazgul für die Couch. Warum hat keiner denn Nazgul eigentlich diese Kordeln aus den Kapuzen? Das stimmt. Warum hatte man die früher nicht? Das stimmt. Früher waren einfach diese, auch Jedi, Jedis, Jedi, hatten nicht Kordeln. Die haben einfach nur diese Kapuzen.
Was haben die Nazgul eigentlich die zehn Millionen Jahre in Minas Morgul gemacht, als kein Ringträger da war? Pokerrunde? Also gechillt, Pokerrunde? Online-Poker. Sehr gut, sehr gut. Du hast hier Publikum in der Hand. Einfach so einen Podcast gemacht, der Nazgul-Cast. Der Nazgul-Cast.
Wow, war das die schlechteste
Nazgul-Imitation aller Zeiten?
Oh, da wird es wieder
Threads hageln im Helder-Ringe-Forum.
Flo, den Weg an, kein Nazgul imitieren.
Ich sehe schon die Hobbit-Ohren da hinten.
Aber wir hatten heute,
gerade hatten wir Backstage lustigerweise
eine interessante Imitation. Erkennt ihr das?
Oh ja, das ist gut. Pass auf, das ist echt krass. Erkennt ihr das, pass auf. Aus welchem Film kommt das? Wer hat's erkannt, wer hat's erkannt? Nee, das war anders. Ja, vielleicht was anders. Skype? Skype? Ach, Gott, oh, Gott, oh, Gott, oh, Gott. Welcher Film? Skypes! Ey, die Studenten von heute, das will ich jetzt verzeihungswerden. Ja, genau die E-Box! Es hat genau das Horn. Es war einfach, weil es Star Wars und Stefan. Ja, aber gut, es ist einfach. Aber die machen genau das Geräusch. Ich glaube ja, jeder Mensch kann eine Imitation, perfekt. Und wenn sich alle Menschen zusammentun... Oh meinst du, Oster Matze Knob,cken alle. Shit ey. Ich kann diesen alten Medizin-Roboter von Star Wars Episode 3, der, der, wie heisst er, Anakin mitteilt, nee, Obi-Wan mitteilt, dass Papa Schlumpf, nee, dass Super Mario das nächste Level nicht erreicht. Warte, warte. Super Mario kriegt die Einladung von Hogwarts nicht.
Genau, ja.
Der und der Roboter, der die schlechten Nachrichten überbringen muss. Droide! Och Gott! Droide, ja, okay. Und den kann ich ihm mit dir in Achtung, pass auf, ihr fühlt euch gleich zurückversetzt ins Jahr 2009. Dubai, Dubai, Dubai.
Ja, ja, Dubai.
Ja, ja, ihr habt's erkannt.
Ihr habt euch alle erinnert gefühlt an die Szene in Star Wars, in der sich ein geschlossener Kinosaal dachte.
Was?
What the fuck?
Sie ist gestorben.
Warum ist sie krank oder so?
Nee, sie hat den Willen zu leben verloren.
Ich auch gerade, by the way. Ich auch jetzt gerade. Ja, das stimmt. Furchtbare, furchtbare Stelle. Ach ja, aber ich bin echt so ein bisschen, also seit ich dieses Foto gesehen habe von mir im Zug, ähm, vielleicht, also, vor allem eure Kommentare auch darunter. Ja, vor allem deine. Ja, vor allem deine. Hat Stefan sein Kind in Köln vergessen, wow, vermissten Anzeige für Stephans Kind, wo man auch mal sagen muss, hast du gesagt, ich habe drei Kinds, ich kann dir eins abgeben. So, Lucie Gang, wir haben uns herzlich amüsiert. Danke. Drei Kinder, ich kann dir eins abgeben. Warum ist bei mir kein Kind falsch und bei ihm sind drei Kinder falsch? Was ist die richtige Anzahl von Kinden? Eins! Eins! Eins! Eins! Ach ja, ist gut. Ist richtig, völlig richtig. Eins ist gut. What the fuck? Man macht einen Gag und Leute rufen mir eigentlich die richtige Antwort rein. Es ist schlecht eigentlich. Man hat ja alles... Nee. Man hat, genau alles was auf der Mitte, ich kann es auch sagen. Sagt du?
Man hat alles zweimal, ausser alles was in genau der Mitte des Körpers liegt.
Ausser das Herz.
Und die Milz.
Und die Leber.
Und die Leber vielleicht.
Und sein Handyhalter an der Seite.
Und der Tumor, der bei mir wahrscheinlich ein bisschen weiter links ist. Ja, naja, ich habe jetzt auch selber schon Maßnahmen ergriffen und habe überlegt, abzunehmen. Ich habe jetzt diese App, die mir dabei hilft. Ich glaube, keine wirklich erfolgreich werdenden Geschichten fangen an mit, ich habe jetzt diese App gefunden, die sich dabei hält. Das stimmt schon. Ich habe sehr viel Stress, habe diese Meditations-App und zwei Wochen später Selbstmord. Das sind immer die Geschichten, hilft oft nicht. Aber ich habe diese App gefunden, die mir erlaubt, in diverse Fitnessstudios zu gehen. Du bezahlst quasi einmal und das Geniale daran ist, monatlich kündbar. Leute, damit haben die ja jetzt schon gewonnen, gegenüber allen Fitnessstudios, weil die nicht monatlich kündbar sind. Ist das genial? Ja, es ist genial. Und, kurze Frage, seit du diese App insediert hast, wie oft warst du im Fitnessstudio? Und zwar, lass mich darauf mit einer leichten kleinen Geschichte weiterkommen, und zwar ist es nämlich so, dass nicht nur Fitnessstudios drin sind, sondern auch Wellnessangebote. Und wenn jemand Wellness gibt, dann steffert. Jetzt stell die Frage nochmal. Wie oft hast du dich seitdem massieren lassen? Nee, ich war tatsächlich aber einmal, ich habe noch keinen Sport gemacht, tatsächlich. Ich war nur wirklich einmal in der Therme. Ich war in der fucking Therme. Und es war unglaublich anstrengend für mich. Weil, man kennt das ja, man will ja, also man sieht selten Leute die Dinge zum ersten Mal machen. Du siehst auch, die Metapher, die ich gerne benutzen möchte, ist, du siehst auch nicht, wie Jogger anfangen zu joggen. Ja, das ist gut, das stimmt. Oder aufhören, das ist ja noch selten aufhören. Oder eine Ampel vielleicht, manche ziehen es durch, aber die machen dann noch so ein bisschen weiter. Aber die meisten Joggen, die siehst du einfach nur Joggen. Du siehst die nicht aufhören zu joggen. So, und bei mir ist es auch so, wenn mich Leute beobachtet haben, wenn ich in der Thermal war, haben sie gesehen, dass ich zum ersten Mal in der so eine scheisse Thermal war. Man muss ja auch lernen, sich zu entspannen, ne, völlig richtig. Aber, ganz kurz, Thermal ist einfach ein warmes Schwimmbad, oder? Nur damit wir alle auf einer Ebene sind. Was genau ist eine Thermal? Erstmal, ich dachte ja, ich dachte auch, es wäre so einfach, aber dann kommt man da rein und man kriegt einen Plan von der Therme. Aber so ein Plan, der so gross ist wie wenn man im Freizeitpark ist. Diese Pläne, wo verschiedene Attraktionen zu finden sind und so. Und dann läufst du halt mit dem Bademantel rum mit den anlassenen Händen, mit diesem grossen Plan, der so langsam zerfleddert und aussieht wie eine Karte aus dem alten Ägypten. Und dann läufst du halt da rum und versuchst dich zu entspannen. Idee, der Plan ist das Handtuch. Ja. Oder? Mega Idee. Man kriegt ein grosses Handtuch, was der Plan für die Terme ist. Das ist ein sehr konkretes... Mega gute Idee. Niemand verlässt den Raum, okay? Ich ruf jetzt meinen Steuerberater an. Mega gut, schließ die Türen ab mal kurz. Das haben wir geprobt, schließ mal kurz die Türen ab. Aber das ist wirklich eine gute Idee. Und dann bin ich halt da rumgeschwommen und dann geht's ja, es ist wirklich erst mal nur ein grosses Becken. Und dann fragt man sich schon, ich wusste halt nicht schon, schwimmt man in diesem Becken? Weil die meisten Leute treiben so am Rand, an diesen Düsen. Und dann gehe ich halt in dieses Becken langsam rein und dann, ich bin halt auch gross, das heißt das Wasser ging mir bis hier ungefähr. Dann ist die Frage dann gehe ich halt in dieses becken langsam rein und ich bin halt auch
groß das wasser ging mir bis hier ungefähr dann ist die frage gehe ich jetzt in den außenbereich
aber man sieht nur man sieht nicht wie wirkt er sich fort man sieht nur meinen kopf aber Aber Achtung, warte, Idee, mach den Fifty-Fifty.
Ja, ja, ja.
Gehen und schwimmen.
Vielleicht springen ist es schlecht.
Aber man geht of both words. Und dann bin ich halt... Hattest du, warst du so in der Therme. Ja klar, ich habe halt das Badeschort an, dann laufe ich so rum. Und dann gab es aber auch eine andere Attraktion, und das ist beantwortet in der Frage, nämlich, es gab nämlich nicht nur dieses grosse warme Becken, es gab auch das unverschämt heisse Becken, von dem ich, weil ich diesen Plan nicht gelesen habe, nicht wusste, weil ich den mit rum, weil es kein Handbuch war, wie du es richtig sagst, und dann bin ich halt reingelaufen in diese ultraheisse Grotte und man sah halt nicht, wohin die führt, das hieß Grotte, ich habe danach den Plan gelesen, die Heissgrotte. Das war einfach so ein Halbkreis und dann bin ich da rein und es war scheisse heiß. Es war unglaublich heiß. Das heißt, dann bin ich so lang gelaufen und dann habe ich die Augen zugekniffen, weil es so heiß war, habe aber nicht gesehen, dass die fucking ganze Grotte voller Menschen war. Es war unglaublich, dann bin ich halt, er ist zum ersten irgendwie auf dem Knöchel gelaufen und so und alle sind dann so nach wie, sind alle so wütend aufgesprungen und so, und die meisten Leute, wenn ich die für einen Film casten müsste, wären so, kennt ihr Dan Bilzerian von Instagram, dieser Typ mit seinen Knarren und so, der so Dwayne The Rock Johnson-artige Figur hat. Das ist ein sehr reicher, sehr muskulöser Mensch. Ja, und die alle waren so unfassbar muskulös und hatten diese unfassbar grossen, schönen Frauen, und ich bin halt so ein Vollidiot durchgestolpert und so. Du bist sogar im Wasser gestolpert, du bist sogar unter Wasser ganz langsam. Ja genau, man stolpert langsam. Oh nein! Ich finde es aber auch gut, dass deine Reaktion, wenn es heiß wird, ist, die Augen zuzumachen. Ja, es war halt so heiß so. Immer doch. Warum? Ich hätte in der Steinzeit auch wirklich keine Minute überlebt. Wenn Gefahr ist, erst mal Augen zu. Aber dann bin ich da rumgelaufen und die ganze Grotte war voll. So, jetzt konnte ich aber nicht diesen Halbkreis gehen und dann einfach wieder rausgehen. Das hat der Stolz in mir nicht zugelassen, weil diese Attraktion zu begehen und dann wieder rauszugehen. Das wollte ich halt nicht. Also bin ich da reingegangen und dann waren wirklich alle Plätze belegt und dann sß ich schon, dass ein anderer sass auch auf einer Treppe, die wieder rausführt. Da habe ich mich einfach neben den auf diese Treppe gesetzt. Jetzt steht dann da, dass man das nur eine Viertelstunde machen soll. Die ganze Grotte ist voll und dann kann man rausgehen, wenn man fertig ist, diese Viertelstunde, und dann ist oben eine so eine Eistonne, wo man sich reinknien kann. Und dann ist der Kreislauf toll in Schwung usw. und dann kann man wieder rausgehen. So, das musst du machen am Ende von diesem Prozedere. Jetzt war das Problem, immer wenn ich dachte, ich wäre jetzt dran, kam halt einer, weil die ganze Grotte war halt voll, kam halt einer raus. So, was dazu führte, immer wenn ich dachte, okay jetzt kann ich gehen, kam halt ein anderer Rad raus, weil seine Viertelelstunde vorbei war, hat sich halt so souverän in diese Eistonne gesetzt. Heißt, ich hatte bestimmt anderthalb Stunden in diesem fucking heißen Wasser und bin so immer aufgequollener geworden. Du warst durch, du warst einfach durch. Ja, das war einfach wahnsinnig anstrengend, wo man sagt, ich bin in dieser Termin um zu entspannen, okay, jetzt geh du dich in die scheisse Eistonne, okay? Und das war wirklich anstrengend. Und dann, was auch wahnsinnig anstrengend war, ist, dann bin ich wieder rausgegangen in dieses Wasser, bin ich wieder durchs Wasser gelaufen. Wie diese Ends, die Ends bei Inisengard. Ja, ich glaube, die haben die auch unter Wasser gedreht, damit das realistisch aussieht. Alle Ends jetzt ins Becken. Genau, und dann gibt es diesen Strudel, wo man dann halt reinschwimmt und dann beschleunigen dich die Düsen am Rand so sehr, dass du einfach nur treiben musst und du treibst im Kreis. So, und in der Mitte ist ein Whirlpool. Völlig egal, aber ich dachte, ich beschreibe die Szene einfach mal. Und dann tatsächlich bist du dann draußen rumgeschleudert immer und es ist halt cool, es macht halt Spaß für drei Umdrehungen. Dann willst du raus, du denkst, du willst zumindest mal erfahren, wie es ist, wieder normal zu leben und dieses kurz, dieses Delirium zu verlassen. Du willst erst mal deine Badehose wieder suchen und erst mal noch mal dich sammeln. Du willst vor allem, du willst dir einreden, dass du da wieder rauskommst. Spoiler, man kommt da nicht wieder raus. Stefan ist bis zum heutigen Tage in diesem Kreisstrudel gefangen. Man musste mich da heute morgen rausholen. Feuerwehrmänner mussten ihn rausschneiden. Und dann habe ich verstanden, warum die ganzen Frauen mit diesen Dwayne-The-Rock-Johnson-artigen Menschen dann da waren, weil die standen immer am Rand von diesem Umkreis und haben halt ihre Frau, wie so Entenangeln in Berkirmes, haben die die so haben die die genau wieder rausgezogen. Clever. Und ich stand dann da und niemand hat mich rausgezogen. Hä, Hilfe! Ich komme nicht wieder raus! Und dann haben sie halt einen so einen Zivi abgestellt, der daneben steht und guckt, dass da niemand verunglückt, weil wenn Ommas dann falsch angepustet werden, dann drehen die sich manchmal. Das ist dann saugebärlich und dann muss es abgeschaltet werden und sowas. Und was ist das für eine Therme eigentlich? Ich stelle mir das vor wie so ein Bratwurststand, der immer mal wieder diese Leute umdreht, wenn sie zu heiß werden. Und dann zumindest mal die andere Richtung. Dann bin ich bestimmt fünfzehn Umdrehungen wieder rumgeschleudert, dann habe ich aktiv versucht, was gegen diese Situation zu tun. Und dann hängen da ja am Rand schon so diese, wie man das kennt, diese Geländer, wo man sich festhalten kann. Aber Wasser hat einfach ungepassbare Stärke und es reißt sich wieder um. Und dann wollte ich halt diesem Zivin nicht das Gefühl geben, mich retten zu müssen. Ich wollte ihm diesen Gefallen nicht tun. Das ist der gesamte Lebensinhalt einfach. Ja, diesen 24-Jährigen da rauszuziehen. Der muss seine alte Omas da raus, dafür sei er ja da. Aber er sollte nicht mich da rausholen. Also habe ich ihn immer angeschaut und mich dann wieder losgelassen weil ich habe gemerkt ich schaff's nicht ich schaff's nicht raus ich schaff's nicht raus hab ich dann losgelassen und er schon so willst du doch da drin sein aber ich habe ihm das Gefühl gegeben so dass es mir wann nicht Spaß macht weil ich wollte nicht zugegeben ich wollte ihm ich wollte nicht zugeben dass ich dass ich zu schwach bin mich da rauszuziehen also wurde ich wieder umgeschleudert und habe mich dann festgehalten, weil ich raus wollte, jetzt hier, wie guckt mich an, ist alles okay? Ich wollte ihm halt das Gefühl geben, ja, ja, alles gut. Und habe mich dann wieder losgelassen, als wäre das mein Thing. Als hätte ich Bock darauf, mich festzuhalten und dann wieder, ja, wieder im Schwung. Und das ging wirklich lächerlich lange, bis ich irgendwann den Dreh raus hatte, weil du musst dann tatsächlich, weil wenn Strahl kommt, wirst du entweder in die Richtung, ja das ist schwierig für die Leute, die zuhören, aber oder in die andere Richtung und dann musst du dich halt genau in den Strahl stellen und dann den einen Schlenker nach links machen mit der Hüfte und dann kommst du raus, da kannst du dich so rausdrehen. So, das steht nirgendwo erklärt. Also, falls ihr mal gefangen seid, ruft Stefan an, er kann euch helfen. Das ist der Wahnsinn. Wow. Ich habe auch, mir ist gerade so eine unfassbar unangenehme Situation eingefallen, Schwimmbad. Ich war als Kind viel im Schwimmbad und bei uns gab es drei Phasen. Drei Phasen im Schwimmbad, entweder Wasserfall von oben, lame, oder Blubber von unten, lame, oder Düse von der Seite, gut.
So, Düse von der Seite, gut. Und ich sag mal so, im Laufe des Lebens eines Menschen, gerade in der Pubertät, erwecken sie, ja, ihr wisst ganz genau von der Rede. Die erste Reihe ruft MeToo. Ja, ja, ja. Und das war natürlich dann bei mir auch so, dass ich irgendwann mal, man ist ja so an dieser Düse oder so, an verschiedenen Körperstellen und merkt, oh, das fühlt sich ja gar nicht so schlecht an. Das fühlt sich sehr gut an. Und es gab auch sehr viele Düsen in der Therme dann. Richtig, ja, genau. Auf verschiedenen Höhen. Und ja, ja, ja, und irgendwann geht man ins Schwimmbad gar nicht so sehr, um zu schwimmen, sondern vor allem wegen diesen Düsen, die alle fünfzehn Minuten fünf Minuten lang an sind. Also auch von da wirklich Druck. Und jetzt, also das war wirklich so ein Stadt-Stadt-Schwimmbad, ja, wo wirklich die Kinder halt aus der Stadt waren, wirklich wenig los. Und halt so ein Bademeister, der halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, jede Hoffnung in seinem Leben verloren hat und irgendwie nur noch gar nichts mehr hat. Und der war dann immer in so einer kleinen kleinen Sly-Mäuschen am Rand des Beckens. Und der ist ja nicht doof. Der hat irgendwann auch gecheckt, dass die ganzen 13-, 14-jährigen Kinder da an dieser einen Stelle sich dann immer da so auflegen und so. Und der hat natürlich da keinen Bock, irgendwie den halben Genpool von meinem Ort da irgendwie aus dem Wasser. Genpool? Ja, Genpool! Genpool! Genpool! Schau, das war wohl nicht dein Thema, mach's gut. Schau Mama, wir wussten, dass der Moment irgendwann kommt. Ah, und er hat sich jemandem nicht getraut, noch mitzugehen. Da ist jemand mitgelaufen, ich habe auf sie gezeigt und sie ist wieder abgewogen und zurückgelaufen. Okay, nicht mit mir. Sehr gut. Und der Bademeister war natürlich dumm und der hat ja nicht dumm und der hat ja keinen Bock darauf, dass die Kinder da ständig kommen. Aber was soll der denn machen? Was? Die sind dann da gekommen? Nein, stopp, stopp, stopp. Hast du gesagt? Stopp. Die wollen, der will nicht, dass die immer kommen.
Du kannst natürlich, nein, der Bademeiser hat keinen Bock, dass das stattfindet so. Und der kann jetzt natürlich nicht als 42er Harald zu Linda hingehen und sagen, du, pass mal auf. Ja, wie ist mir das aufgefallen? Ich weite, das ist ja so, so kindliche Sexualität muss man ja einfach ausblenden. Man kann ja nicht drüber reden, weil man einfach immer denkt, warum ist Ihnen das aufgefallen?
Das heißt, die einzige Chance, die dieser arme, arme Mensch hatte, der den ganzen Tag da saß und nur dummen, ejakulierenden Kindern zugeguckt hat, das war sein Lebensinhalt.
Für einen selbst sind es fünf Minuten pro Woche, für den ist es vierundschweißig sieben.
Ah, da kommen sie wieder, da kommt die nächste Schulklasse. Und der wollte einfach, dass das aufhört. Aber was soll man denn machen? Du kannst ja nicht die Düse ausmachen. Was er gemacht hat ist, sein Häuschen war direkt da und dann irgendwann kamen dann, weil er wusste ja auch, wann die Düsen an sind, die Düsen kamen und dann auch zufällig kamen dann die ganzen Jugendlichen und dann haben sie da hingelegt. Und was er gemacht hat, er ist einfach aus seinem Häuschen gegangen und hat denen einfach in die Augen geschaut. Die Jugendlichen, die da am Beckenrand einfach so, den hier. Und seitdem hat Sebastian Edati einen neuen Job. Viel zu sp hat den einfach in die Augen geschaut, in der Hoffnung, dass denen es so unangenehm ist, dass sie aufhören, weil man hat ja keine andere Chance. Und das war einfach, und der Plan ist nicht schlecht, weil es ist durchaus unangenehm, aber jetzt steckst du natürlich im pubertierenden Körper eines fünfzehnjährigen. Und starrst Knallern zurück. Und starrst zurück und siehst den ganzen Tag Nachtelfen und denkst dir dann, okay, ich muss ins Schwimmbad.
Und dann stehst du da und starrst einem 50-Jährigen in die Augen und denkst dir, das ist jetzt mein Sexleben, also so sei es. Es wurde seitdem auch nicht besser, um dein Sex zu sein. Aber so, ja, so, tatsächlich, so wurde eine ganze Generation erwachsen in meinem Heimatort. Sexualität ist vielseitig. Es ist wirklich vielseitig. Es ist auch im Schwimmbad. Aber ich hatte auch so Mitleid mit dem Mann, weil der, was soll der denn machen? Also der kann nicht anders sich wehren, als darauf zu pochen, dass sie einen Hauch Anstand haben. Und ach. Bei dem gleichen Blick, den du beschrieben hast gerade, wie er dich die Kinder anguckt, den hat er auch dieser Zieh wie bei mir in diesem Training. Ja. Weil er irgendwann so dachte, vielleicht ist es seine Art, vielleicht ist es seine Sexualität. Es gibt Erbjekte viele, er steht auf diese Kreise im Schwimmbad. Ja, es ist ja auch so, die menschliche Evolution, die erste Eskalationsstufe ist, man schaut jemandem in die Augen und dann hofft man, dass der aufhört mit dem, was er gerade macht. Das habe ich im Interviewtraining gelernt, dass man Leute, wenn man will, dass Leute sich verhaspeln, einfach in die Augen schaut. Weil Leute sind es nicht gewohnt. Ne, Leute sind es nicht gewohnt, dass man die ganze Zeit in die Augen schaut. Aber das ist wirklich die erste Eskalationsstufe und mehr hast du nicht. Und deswegen kann ich schon verstehen, dass auch in der S- in der s bahn gut er könnte die düsen abstellen dann sind da unbewachte löcher in der wand ich weiss nicht ob das ob das vielleicht sind die düsen auch nur um einfach mal durchzuspüren ich habe leute man weiss nicht komm leute ähm uuuuh ich meine bei mir ist es auch so der journalist im raum macht sich nur die zu Auf den letzten Metern gingen ihm die Gags aus. Ach Gott, aber es ist einfach so. Naja, ich meine, es ist wirklich eine Generation, die keinen Pornhub hatte, musste einfach irgendwo alles hin. Poolhub. Ich meine, die Kinder, die heute erwachsen, überhaupt kein Problem. Die finden im Internet alles, was sie brauchen. Und wir hatten das nicht. Ja, und so im ICE zum Beispiel auch, wenn jemand laut ist, schaue ich ihm in die Augen. So einfach, und das war's. Und mehr Eskalationsstufe habe ich nicht. Ich versuche Probleme dadurch zu lösen, dass ich Leuten in die Augen gucke. Ja, aber es funktioniert nicht, da geht gar nichts. Aber ist dir mal aufgefallen, dass Babys die besten Menschen sind im Blickduellen? Du hast keine Chance, ja keine Chance, die Babys. Babys sind die Warlords der scheiss Blickduelle, die können das, die schauen ruhig durch, das ist dem scheiss egal. Du kannst, ich wollte mal irgendwann, also ich habe es mit Hunden versucht, weil bei Hunden habe ich gelernt, irgendwann, dass man, wenn man lange anschaut, das ist dann, what the f... Ist das dir die Flasche lebt. Hunde, wenn du die anschaust und die gucken weg, dann bist du der Boss. Ich glaube, ich war in meinem Leben, wenn es hochkommt, einmal der Boss bei Hunden. Meistens waren sie der Boss und sie haben es auch gezeigt. Und bei Babys hast du wirklich gar keine Chance. Und da habe ich dann immer gelernt, dass man das bei Hunden machen sollte. Und da dachte ich mir, so ist es mal mit kleinen Menschen, aber menschen aber da habe ich schon verloren es ist wirklich ein problem vor allem ist es wirklich immer so dass wenn man ein baby so so ein erwachsener mensch trägt das baby auf so dass das kind nach hinten guckt und man läuft dahinter ich glaube jeder mensch reflexartig es wackelt dann auch so ja schon schaut das kind an und schneidet grimassen und irgendwie keine ahnung erklärt ihm wie der zweite weltkrieg ausgebrochen ist oder einfach erzählt ihm einfach bullshit und ich glaube es. Und ich glaube, das ist einfach so ein Reflex, wenn man Kinder sieht, dann einfach furchteinflößigere Massen zu machen. Das Kind ist völlig verstört einfach, wenn die Eltern das sehen würden, was die den ganzen Tag abbekommen. Es ist übrigens... Warum ist der so? Warum ist der so gross? Warum wird mein Kind immer grösser? Es hört nicht auf. Mein neues Hobby ist, mir Videos anzuschauen, wenn Kinder Dinge machen, die Erwachsene tun.
Oh, okay!
Nein, nein, nein!
Das war's für nur für uns, gut, schon!
Schöne Jahrhundern! Okay, Leute, ernsthaft, ernsthaft, ernsthaft.
Wo komme ich aus dieser Einbahnstrasse einer Anmoderation wieder raus?
Okay.
Red noch, red noch weiter, red weiter. Man kennt das ja, man ist alleine zuhause abends, man ist einsam, so und dann geht man auf YouTube und man ist plötzlich in so einer YouTube-Spirale und man klickt auf die angebotenen Videos und plötzlich landet man halt bei dem Video, wie Kinder Eishockey spielen und sich verbrübeln. Ah, okay, ja, ist klar.
Und das ist wirklich lustig, weil es gibt Videos, weil Kinder, Eishockey spielende Kinder gucken, gucken Eishockey und sehen, dass die Erwachsenen sich verprügeln. Aber die sehen halt nicht, dass es da oft Wortwächste gab und so weiter dazwischen. Und das heißt, dann gibt es diese Videos von Kindern, die einfach sich begrüssen, die einfach in dieser Reihe stehen, weil die Teams sich zum Anfang begrüssen und dann fangen sie an, sich zu verprügeln. Es gibt Compilations davon, besucht mich mal auf Twitter, ich habe das mal irgendwann rausgehauen, es war mega. Besucht mich mal auf Twitter. Wie so ein VDR4-Moderator, der es gerade erdeckt hat. Red ich noch mit dir oder mit dem Tumor? Er hat wie Ratatouille so langsam die Steuerung übernommen. Ja, was machst du mit dem Mikrofonstern? Aber das ist wirklich wahnsinnig lustig. Ich finde das auch gut, weil Kinder imitieren ja alles, was Erwachsenen haben. Und irgendwie so, ah, die machen seine eigene Pressekonferenz irgendwie, unser Transferhandel und alle sind der Manager dann da. Alles Kinder einfach. Und es gibt dieses grandiose Video, was irgendwann so ein Elternmagazin
in Zusammenarbeit mit Psychologen gezeigt hat. Genau, Psychologen wie dir. Und die tolle Idee war, zehn Jungs im Alter von zehn bis elf Jahren. Das fucking Christ! Man kommt aber auch nicht raus.
So, und zwar war die Prämisse dieses Tests war, wir gucken mal was passiert, wenn wir zehn Jungs im Alter von zehn Jahren alleine im Haus lassen. Das ist das ganze Video. Mit welcher Musik? Das Video ist einfach 40 Minuten lang und es hat so einen geilen Kommentator, der die ganze Zeit sagt, so jetzt haben die Jungs William zu ihrem Anführer gemacht. Und es klingt einfach wie so eine Doku über Schimpansen, ganz ehrlich. Und man muss ja auch sagen, dass zehnjährige Kinder jetzt nicht viel weiter sind als Schimpansen. Vielleicht ein bisschen. Also, bo von zehnjährigen Kindern da. Ne, viele Fans von Schimpansen da. Hey, Schimpansen! Und es ist wahnsinnig lustig, weil man denkt ja, bestimmt machen die das Haus kaputt. Naja, aber vielleicht kommen sie irgendwie auch auf interessante Ideen. Die haben halt davor, haben halt jeder einen individuellen Kochkurs besucht. Die wurden halt alleine gelassen in diesem Haus für zehn Tage lang. Da müssen die ja was essen. Und die Prämisse war, die Prämisse war... Was? Richtig! Elfjährig? Genau, und dieses Video gibt es auf YouTube, Leute, das ist mega. Und das ganze Haus ist halt voll. Das Haus ist voller Essen. Moment, ist das ein Märchen? Was? Das Haus ist voller Lebkuchen. Ja, genau. Die Kinder können machen, was sie wollen. Und dann kommen die drei Schweine. Und das ist Wahnsinn, das Video. Aber die werden halt alleine gelassen. Die haben alle vor den Kochgerüst bekommen, damit sie überleben können. Die ganze Zeit ist dieses Doku-Team dabei, was nur eingreift, falls es gefährlich wird. Spoiler, es wurde mehrere Male gefährlich. Und es gibt diesen Buzzer im Haus, wo man draufhauen kann, um die Kinderpsychologin zu holen.
Und die Kinder dürfen die Kinderpsychologin holen? Die Kinder dürfen die Kinderpsychologin holen.
Ist die Kinderpsychologin auch ein Kind? Nein. Na, okay.
Nein. Und das Dokumentarsteam ist auch keine Kinder. Full Disclaimer. Und das ist wirklich
genial, weil diese, das gibt eine Dreiviertelel Stunde lang, sieht man halt diese Kinder alleine da in diesem Haus und es sind nur Jungs, es gibt auch ein Video, wo Mädchen das machen, ich habe es noch nicht angeguckt, weil ich dachte, ich freue mich nach wie vor darüber über das Video und es ist wirklich Wahnsinn, weil wenn du dann, ich habe da mal irgendwann so ein bisschen vorgescrollt direkt, weil ich nicht erwarten konnte, wie das Haus nachher aussieht. Und ich hab zu doll vorgescrollt, weil du musst nur zwei Minuten von dieser 45-Minuten-Doku nach vorne scrollen und das Haus ist weg. Es ist unglaublich. Menschen in einem Alter von zehn Jahren kriegen nichts hin. Keine Strukturen, kein Kind wechselt jemals die Klamotten. Kein Kind isst was anderes, ausser einen so ein Opfer, der gemobbt wird. Ein Kind isst eine Tiefkühlpizza, die haben Kochkurs vorher besucht. Minute vierzehn schüttet jemand Milch in ein Ei. Es ist der Wahnsinn. Und die essen nichts, also ausser Müsli. Die hauen sich die ganze Zeit Fruit Loops rein und Cola. Und irgendwann stapeln sich so die Cola-Dosen und die Fruit Loops-Kartons. Und die kommen gerade rein, es fängt schon lustig an, die kommen rein und alle kriegen eine Kamera geschenkt, damit die Eindrücke sammeln können. Das war irgendwie so ein nes Gadget, dieses Test, der hat eine Kamera bekommen. Dann kam Michael, hat alle Kameras genommen und gegen die Wand geworfen. Und dann waren erstmal alle Kameras weg und die Gruppe war skeptisch gegenüber Michael. Und dann ist der Tag langsam vergangen und die Gruppe hat beschlossen, dass Michael zum Problem wird.
Und dieser Voice-Over-Kommentar sagt das auch die ganze Zeit. Die Gruppe hat erkannt, dass Michael zu einem ernsthaften Problem geworden ist. Deswegen beschliessen sie, einen Anführer zu wählen. Und dann kommen die halt wirklich, was irgendwie lustig ist, weil die Kinder dann beschliessen, dass sie einen Anführer brauchen, und kommen dann halt zusammen in der Sofa-Ecke, die auch schon alle Wände sind, übrigens sind schon bemalt, und kommen dann zu dem Schluss, dass sie William zum Anführer wählen,
der aber dann nichts anderes macht, als Michael manchmal zu sagen, dass er diesen Scheiss einfach sein lassen soll. Und wie gesagt, die waschen sich nicht einmal und erst an Tag sieben oder so kommen sie auf die Ideen, ein Community-Meal zu machen, also zusammen zu essen. und tragen dann, aus welchem Grund auch immer, während Michael, der die Kamera zerstört hat, mit dem Fahrrad im Garten Kreise fährt und schreit, weil er testen will, wie viel er schreien muss, damit er keine Stimme mehr hat, im Kreis und in der Mitte gibt's dieses Community-Meel statt, aus irgendeinem Grund, fangen die dann einfach an, da zu essen und haben dann zwei Jungs kochen lassen. Und die haben halt Hackfleisch dann gemacht, aber die haben es einfach, ich glaube, die haben nicht mal richtig, und da ging auch der Feueralarm an, weil die das anbrennen lassen haben und so, und der eine hat einfach, dieser eine Junge, die ganze Zeit gemobbt wurde, vor allem von Michael, hat dann zu viel bekommen, hat sich einfach so eine Tiefkühlpizza reingemacht. Und ich dachte mir, ja, ich habe für den geroutet, obwohl das seine Leistung war, eine Tiefkühlpizza reinzumachen nach einem wöchigen Kochkurs.
Das ist der Wahnsinn. Ten Boys Home Alone ist das Video.
Ich traue ihm immer noch nicht.
Es ist Wahnsinn.
Und dann am Ende bilden sich zwei Banden, die in gegenüberliegenden Zimmern liegen. Liegen? Naja, wenn ich schlafe, liegen die halt. Und dann liegen die einen im anderen Zimmer, die anderen in der anderen und dann püren sich die Nacht die Türen auf, weil die einen beschlossen haben, dass die anderen nicht schlafen sollen. Das ist halt was man auch so macht. Und dann bewerfen die die mit Dingen und das andere und dann sagt der Kommentator und dann kommt es zum Krieg. Und man denkt, what the fuck, greif ein! Es kommt zum Krieg, der Lego-Reichstag brennt. Und dann kommt's zum Krieg und irgendwann wechselt der Rothaarige die Seiten, weil er checkt, aha, die sind mehr als wir, deswegen gewinnen die auch, wechselt die Seiten, unglaublich clever, weil dann manchmal setzt es halt doch irgendwie so menschliche Instinkte ein und denkst so, ja gut, Menschen sind einfach clever, aber die ganze Zeit machen die, die haben nichts Produktives geleistet, die haben nichts gebaut, die haben alles nur eingerissen. Dazu kommt dann irgendwie dieser Dokutyp, kommt dann zu dem Erkenntnis, dass es einfach eine scheisse Idee war, zehn Jungs alleine einzuschliessen. Vor allem Fazit dieser psychologischen Abhandlung, war eine scheisse Idee. Ja, sorry. Aber und da glaube ich wirklich, so viel man auch gegen Social Media und so sagt, ich glaube wirklich, dass wenn man jetzt gross wird mit iPhones und iPads und so und besser, ich weiss nicht, ob es so doof wie die Theorie ist, aber wenn man lernt, sich mit sich selber zu beschäftigen und schon mal diesen Blick in die Welt hat, ich glaube, also vielleicht wäre es heute anders. Also vielleicht würden die furchtbaren Scheiss machen auf dem iPhone oder sowas. Aber ich kann mir wirklich vorstellen, dass heutzutage würden die alle auf ihr iPhone gucken. Wir können das Experiment gerne wiederholen. Wir haben eine Person im Publikum, die das hinkriegen kann. Die Kinderpsychologin wird. Ihr musst nur wirklich aufpassen. Ja, sie nickt. Sehr gut. Wirklich geil. Genau, und dann ist der Krieg ausgebrochen und dann haben die gesagt, nope, nope, das ist der Punkt, wo wir sagen, das geht nicht mehr und die haben die Kinderpsychologin geholt,
haben sie dann auf den Buzzer gehauen, gemeinschaftlich, um dann Michael rauszumoffen.
Weil die haben gesagt, der hat vor Anfang an die Kamera kaputt gemacht, haben sie vielleicht gesehen, hätten sie da vielleicht schon eingreifen können, haben sie nicht, nehmen sie ihn jetzt bitte mit.
Ach, die Kinder wissen, dass sie überwacht werden. Ja, klar, okay. Da läuft auch eine Kamera mit rum, so dumm sind die auch nicht.
Ach, da ist ein Erwachsener mit Kamera drin. mit kamera drin ja wie gesagt da ist ein dokumentationsteam dabei
was die ganze zeit eingreifen könnte dann fang nochmal von vorne ist aber nicht tun zehn jungs
alleine zuhause und es ist wirklich schau ich jetzt mal an das ist wirklich wahnsinn alter ich
weiß was ich heute abend anschauen werde ich google mal zehn jungs ten boys hot alone. It's getting hot. Hot milk and egg. Things get dirty. And things get dirty. Aber, Milch und Ei, hat das funktioniert? Ich weiß nicht genau. Ich weiß nicht genau. Vor allem, da muss es doch mal irgendwann, da muss es doch Behind-the-Scenes-Material geben. Die waren zehn Tage alleine da zu Hause, die Doku ist 45 Minuten lang.
Wo ist der Rest? Ich will den ganzen Rest sehen.
Wahnsinn, das ist richtig gut.
Hat euch mal eingefallen. Hast du auch diese wahnsinnige Angst, wenn du in Taxi steigst?
Immer noch, dass du im Quiztaxi bist?
Es ist ein Punkt. Ich habe diese Angst, deswegen kam ich gerade drauf, weil als wir von Mannheim auch nach Hause gefahren sind im Taxi, haben wir darüber gesprochen, weil es gab ja auch Menschen, die gesagt haben, ich will nicht gefilmt werden. Ja, und du musst ja generell, wenn du mit Passanten oder so filmst, mit jedem, den du verarscht auf der Strasse oder so, der muss dann nachunterschreiben, dass das Material von ihm gesendetet. Und locker im Schnitt würde ich sagen, 95 Prozent sagen nein. Deswegen, wenn du diese Strassenaufnahmen machst, diese Rab in Gefahrartigen, musst du einfach zwei Tage lang drehen, um halt Leute zu bekommen, die sagen, jo, ich bin dabei. Und da werden ja bestimmt, wie gesagt, 95 Prozent sagen, nee, ich habe jetzt keinen Bock auf Quiztaxi, ich will einfach dringend nach Hause. Und diese Fahrt will ich mir gerne mal anschauen. Musste der dann tatsächlich nach Hause gefahren werden oder musste der aussteigen? Wo lief das? Bei Vox oder wo? Ja, keine Ahnung. Aber vor allem, die haben doch irgendwo einen Giftschrank, wo Millionen Stunden Material von Leuten drin sind. Jetzt willkommen in Quiztaxi! Nee, danke, ich habe wirklich keinen Bock, ich muss nach Hause. I don't speak German, I just want to the airport. Von Leuten, die eine unangenehme Fahrt hatten, weil sie vor allem ein Christ-Taxi sachen. Ja, vor allem der arme Moderator denkt, er ist hier in der Fernsehung und 90% ist er einfach ein normaler Taxifahrer. Ja, genau. Wer hat das moderiert, Elton oder so? Ich hab immer Elton im Kopf. Nee, das war schon ein spezieller Typ, ich glaub, der war vielleicht Taxifahrer vom Beruf. Nee. Man weiss es nicht genau. Der wie, der blonde, wie hieß der denn nochmal? Wie lange müssten wir jetzt nichts sagen, bis die ersten Leute einfach irgendwann gehen? Nee, bis die erste Person gegangen ist. Bis die letzte Person irgendwie die Jacke nimmt und sagt. Warte, wie hieß der denn nochmal? Wie hieß der denn nochmal? Das war immer unser Traum, das wollten wir mal machen als Rubrik auf YouTube, wie lang würde es dauern? Und zwar so eine Art Prankhafte Rubrik, wo man sich immer die Frage stellt, wie lang würde es dauern? Wie zum Beispiel, wenn man vor einem Kino einfach tausend Trailer zeigt vor dem Film. Ja genau. Und wie lang würde es dauern, bis Adler gegangen sind? oder so produktionslogos dann kommt die dann kommt bad robots dann kommen weiß nicht in columbia universal bis ewig leute sagen leute ist bestimmt ein mega film weil sehr viele gute talentierte leute mit gemacht haben dann noch mal 20 century lange wird es dauern, bis die erste Person gehen? Ja, genau. Ich glaube, wirklich lange. Können wir doch machen. Oder auch sowas wie wenn Beyonce nicht zwei Stunden spielt, sondern einfach so lange spielt und Musik macht, bis die letzte von den 15.000 Leuten im Stadion die letzte Person gegangen ist. Bis selbst die Backing-Singer so sagen. Ja. Oh, la, la la la. Okay, wir müssen nach Hause jetzt. Jo, bester Job der Welt, Backup-Singer, oder? Ist der beste Job der Welt? Ist wirklich der beste Job. Einfach immer diesen. Das ist dein Job. Was machst du? Das hier. Das. Uh la la la, uh la la. Nichts gegen Backup-Singer, das ist fantastisch, aber ich finde es einfach toll. Die unterstützen andere Leute. Wie Stefan, der mich jeden Tag unterstützt. Ich unterstütze jeden Tag. Applaus für Stefan Tietze, meine Damen und Herren. Applaus für Florian Tietze, meine Damen und Herren. Dankeschön. Eine Sache noch kurz, wir erzählen jedes Jahr davon, du bist leider voll rausgegangen, du bist nicht mehr dabei aber ich muss jetzt halt irgendwie noch mal die lanze hochhalten für den comedypreis denn es war die freis war wieder ja und leute gab es nicht genug einladung oder warum hast du mich nicht gefragt weil ich habe gar nicht ich habe dann auf instagram gesehen dass du ein comedypreis bist und nicht pass das so ein tag an und so ach so ja neben tag aber ein plus deswegen... Achso, weil ich hätte keine Zeit gehabt. Ich hätte Zeit gehabt. Ich hätte nichts zu tun oder so. Nichts zu tun mit dem Machen. Nee, gar nichts. Ich habe Tarkan mitgenommen und im Nachhinein hat es sich als Gute rausgestellt. Ah, cool. Das ist doch gut. Freut mich, dass du die richtige Entscheidung getroffen hast für dich. Weil es kam dann irgendwann zu dem... Wir machen Podcast seit drei Jahren und sind unterwegs, Thakan ist ja einmal kurz getroffen, aber... Thakan war auch nominiert. Thakan war auch nominiert für eine gute Show namens Kräumann. Applaus für Kräumann. Schlechtes Applaus, Apola. Aber ähm... Wer war der Comedypreis, was ist die aktuelle Lage? Wie sieht's aus? Die Lage steht schlimm in Deutschland, soviel sehr gesagt. In der Pause hat eine Mariachi-Band für uns gespielt, wo man wirklich denkt, das kann nicht euer Ernst sein. Die haben grosse Hüte auf. Das kann wirklich nicht wahr sein. Komm, schick die raus jetzt! Das ist furchtbar. Es ist eine Mauschelveranstaltung, alle schieben sich die Preise zu. Und mittlerweile muss man sagen, der Comedypreisis wird auch immer mehr gerunterwirtschaftet. Früher gab es noch diesen großen roten Teppich, wo wir noch da waren. Die guten alten Zeiten, wo wir da waren. Und es gab einen roten Teppich und da waren riesen Logos und so weiter. Mittlerweile, und es gab eine Bar vor allem und ein großes Buffet. Mittlerweile steht einfach nur ein Kühlschrank, wo ein paar Bags drinstehen. Und so Guido Kanz und Cindy aus Marzahn gehen halt wie so einer BG-Feier zu diesem Kühlschrank mit diesem Dinger.
Das ist halt mittlerweile der Comedypreis. Also seitdem du nicht mehr dabei bist, läuft es auch nicht mehr da.
Ich möchte an der Stelle kurz sagen, dass ich den Comedypreis weiter unterstütze, vor allem die Jury und die ganzen Organisatoren, ich immer noch sehr, sehr gut finde. Ich habe vor allem, ich habe gemerkt, dass es zwischen mir und der deutschen Comedy einfach
mittlerweile so einen unüberwindbaren Spalt gibt, als sich dann Erkan und Stefan, sorry, Erkan und Stefan hatten ihr grosses Comeback seit zehn Jahren. Und Erkan lief immer noch mit seiner Döner-Tier-Mütze rum, wo er sagt, ja stimmt, das war der eine Gag, den wir immer gemacht haben. Und dann wurden sie irgendwie wieder aufgetaut und laufen plötzlich beim Comedypreis rum. Und ich dachte mir, wie lustig, weil ich bin ja mit Tarkan da. Tarkan und Stefan machen ein Foto mit Erkan und Stefan. Und ich fand es lustig und andere fand es lustig und wir sind halt hingegangen und haben die angesprochen, das war ein bisschen awkward, und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ich bin Stefan und das ist Tarkan.
Keine Reaktion von ihm. Keine Reaktion, er hat halt dieses Handtuch und hat sich halt immer noch, das ist ein ein Prop, hat sich halt ein bisschen die Stirn, weil es warm war, keine Ahnung, das war eine Reaktion, das ist ein Handtuch. so und dann habe ich gesagt okay alles klar wir sind Tarkan und Stefan, wir sind Erkan und Stefan,
wer ist nicht mehr gelust, wenn wir ein Foto machen und dann hat er gesagt, okay, alles klar, ich erklär's mal, wir sind Tarkan und Stefan, wir sind Erkan und Stefan, wer hat sich mega lustig, wenn wir ein Foto machen.
Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, klar, mega witzig, ey. Und dann hat er, beide haben es gleichzeitig auch gleich verstanden, nämlich dann hat Stefan Erkan weggeschoben und hat sich bei mir eingehakt. Also Stefan und Stefan. So, seine Vorstellung des Gags war, dass Stefan und Stefan ein Foto zusammen machen und vielleicht danach irgendwann Tarkan und Erkan. Aber das war seine Vorstellung des Gags, wo man sich dachte, okay, vielleicht bekommt man einfach nicht zusammen. Aber der war dann sehr unangenehm. Die haben auch nicht verstanden, warum wir dann dieses Viererfoto gemacht haben. Wir dachten, wir wären Fans oder so. Vor allem der Stefan Florian Simbeck, der war doch, also die Karriere, also die klassische Karriere, irgendwie fängt an, dann Stefan von Erken und Stefan, SPD-Politiker und wieder Stefan von Erken und Stefan. Der klassische Weg einfach. Wie alle bei dir immer behaupten, dass du Grünpolitiker bist. In jedem Interview bist du gefragt, wie ist es denn so als Grünpolitiker? Ja, das müssen wir jetzt aber auch nicht weiterhin in die Welt tragen. Ich bin kein Grünpolitiker, falls das nicht schon äusserst offensichtlich geworden ist in den letzten Minuten. Flotin, ich freue mich sehr, dass dieser Abend, wie ich finde, ein Erfolg war. Auf jeden Fall. Und ganz kurz was anzukündigen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es schon verfolgt, aber auf Twitter ab sofort haben wir das offizielle Das Podcast UFO Poster. Ja, es ist ab jetzt endlich. Nimm das Mannheim, fick dich Mannheim.
Das ist unsere Art, das zu sagen, fick dich Mannheim. Es ist leider jetzt erst fertig geworden, aber wir haben draußen der tolle Christoph Hoppenbrock, er hat ein ganz tolles Poster für uns gemacht, zu jeder Folge hat er ein kleines Bild gemalt. Mega gut, es gibt viel zu entdecken. Ihr könnt Donny Sullivan entdecken, ihr könnt Oli P. entdecken, ihr könnt raten, welche Folge welche ist, es ist großartig, es ist fantastisch und falls ihr an neuen Hörer keinen Bock habt, alle Folgen nochmal anzuhören, gebt dem das Poster, da sind die als Bildchen drauf, man checkt es dann schon. Der Rest ergibt sich. Wenn ihr Lust habt, kauft das draußen, wenn ihr das Geld überhaupt und Bock drauf habt, ansonsten sehen wir uns gleich auch draußen nochmal, wir sagen nochmal hallo, vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart, mehr geile Abend, es hat echt Spaß gemacht. Haut rein. Vielen Dank, Dankeschön, Hannover.
Dankeschön.
Dankeschön. Vielen, vielen Dank, macht's gut, kommt gut nach Hause. Thank you.